(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, welcome to Roll On,
where today we're gonna peer into the abyss
in all its beauty and pain
and try to make some sense out of this extraordinary planet
and its curious and oftentimes confusing humans.
You guys know the deal,
we rip from the headlines of our mad world,
we address some human stories
from the front lines of endurance,
a few items that have captured our fancy
over the last couple weeks,
we answer listener questions, and we do it all
with a light dusting of frivolity and randomness.
But first, of course, we have to welcome
the misplaced beat poet of the newest millennium,
Mr. Adam Skolnick.
How you going, as the Aussies would say?
Well, I don't know actually, to be honest.
Oh, come on, let's get the energy up, right?
It's been a couple of weeks.
I know, but its been brought to my attention recently
that I've been saying things without my own knowledge,
saying things like, "What's up gang?"
And "Let's rock and roll crew."
And I don't know Rich.
Where is that coming from?
I don't know, it's hard for me to deal with.
I didn't even know I was saying it.
It's an age thing?
I think it's a dad thing.
I've so far been able to stave off the dad bod,
but the dad brain is taking over.
Yeah, you can't stop that, it's a force of nature.
Never in my wildest nightmares did I ever think
I'd ever say something like, "Let's rock and roll, crew."
Well, the dad brain,
wait till the kid gets a little bit older
because you're persistently reminded
about your dad energy and how uncool it is.
(Adam laughing)
Can I be--
That's what being a dad is about.
Can I--
Just embrace it.
I will embrace it.
Can I shrivel back into my dry sardonic self
at some point, like age after age 14?
Just don't expect that it's gonna go
over well with the kid.
Nothing goes over well. (laughs)
Do you say things like, "What's up gang?"
Oh, I do it on purpose now.
I play it up, just ratchet, like just lean into it.
It's more fun that way.
And like, I'm running.
I like how big of an eye roll can I get for this one?
Exactly, that's what I'm gonna have to do.
Right now, he's just happy-go-lucky 18-month-old.
I was running this morning,
just this morning, and passed another dad,
who was walking with his two stroller dads,
the sun's not quite up yet.
And I said, "Hey dad, how's it going?"
Like, what's going on?
What is happening?
What is going on?
That globe-trotting, serious journalist energy
is being displaced with a suburban mindset.
I used to be civilized.
I used, or uncivilized.
Now I'm more civilized, but it feels less civilized.
I don't know how to say it.
Like I said, just lean into it.
I'm leaning in.
But the dad bod issue, we have news from the front lines.
Right, so four by four by 48 happened.
Yeah.
Yes.
The Goggins, the Annual Goggins Challenge in the books.
The Annual Goggins Ultra Festival for the uninitiated.
Yeah, how'd it go for you?
I did, I had injuries going in,
so I wasn't really prepared this time.
And Jason came up to me, I think last time I was here,
and said, "Are you gonna do the Goggins Challenge?"
And I hadn't even thought about doing it
because I'd hurt my back at the beginning of January.
But as his co-author, you have to.
I did--
No choice.
Right.
So what happened was like my back injury ended,
so I ran probably 12 miles in January.
And then in February, like I could start running again,
maybe the second week in February.
I probably ran less than 60 miles in the two months.
Definitely, less than 60 miles
in the two months coming into March.
And so I was thinking, all right,
let me just see how the body is.
So on the Sunday and Tuesday, I did some repetitions.
I did three, three-mile runs on Sunday.
I did four twos on Tuesday.
And if my body held up, I was gonna give it a shot,
but I hadn't felt good running even after even coming back.
I had not had a good run since the, before I got hurt,
I hadn't felt good, my everything was off.
And for some reason, I was ended up faster by almost
an hour in cumulative time, I felt good, my body felt good.
And it's a grind, it's a grind doing it.
April did it with me as well.
She took 72 hours, because she couldn't do
the middle of the night stuff
because we, no one's there to watch Zuma and he wakes up.
So she had to carry it a third day.
She didn't have to do the middle of the night,
she had to carry it a third day.
And Saturday, the winds were howling,
I mean, the winds were bad here,
but the winds were like 40 mile,
like over 30 miles an hour in the desert.
You were out in the desert.
Yeah, and it was like crazy winds, all of Saturday.
Mild hallucinations in the middle
of the night, you see like a street sign,
you think it's a coyote coming
to get you, like just crazy stuff on the second night.
But it's running at night, it's the most nightlife I've had
since Zuma's been, actually since last year,
since this time, last year.
It was the most nightlife I've had in a year.
Well, congrats.
Thank you.
And congrats to Jason as well.
Yes, congrats.
Two team members banked it this year.
And it's interesting that you had a what sounds like
a more pleasant experience doing it this year.
And I think that has to have something
to do with the fact that you've done it before.
So you have that history, you know can do it,
so it's not as anxiety provoking,
even if you hadn't trained adequately for it.
Like you can kind of wrap your head around like,
okay, I know how this is gonna go.
Yeah, the wild card was
will my glutes get twingy, will a lower back lockup?
And so, that was the only...
Like, the four mile runs are one thing,
but that was the wild card
that you couldn't really plan for.
But in the end, like I said, and since then,
it's almost like this jump-started training camp,
'cause since then my running has been better.
I felt better, I feel stronger, so I don't know.
Last time it was like, I did it.
And then I took a little bit
of a break, and got back in the ocean.
And this time I'm kind of riding the momentum a little bit
and trying to get that zone two
back to where I want it to be.
Meanwhile, the mythos of David Goggins continues to grow.
Incredible.
I mean, he was amazing
those videos.
Incredible.
That he shared, like
so many people, he was going up and down the coast
and popping up here and there.
Started in Sacramento area.
And like helicopters following him
and thousands of people, and him leaning out
of SUVs, screaming, and people going nuts.
Like it was really something.
Yeah, he, no, he's a full blown star, you know?
And he's got like the sheriff helicopters shouting out
tributes to him and he flew to Ventura.
He did the middle of the night once, he kept
with just, he and Jennifer, and then had those meetups.
Hermosa, I think was the largest from what they told me.
Hermosa, the over a thousand people down the strand there.
I mean, just what an experience to be there.
And he signed every single book.
He took a picture with every single person that turned up.
He did it all the way through,
and then they had to immediately race down to Costa Mesa.
So like, and get there just in time, and do it all again.
And apparently the final run he finished in sub sevens.
Right, of course.
(Adam laughing)
Good for him, man, unbelievable.
You've been getting out with the whales?
Yes, so it's whale migration season here
in Malibu, so I'm sure everyone...
Well you know about, and people here, local,
in Malibu know about.
So the gray whales are migrating back up past,
Monterey first, and then Alaska
and onto Points North, Bering Sea, I believe.
And so yeah, you get lucky sometimes you get lucky.
So the Malibu artists kind of came.
Usually I meet him in Santa Monica, in the Santa Monica Bay,
but he, this time we met up
at Dume and he flew and was able to get me, I got,
I was swimming and barely saw, I turned and took a breath.
And all of a sudden I see a whale fluke
about 50 feet outside me.
And he happened to get it from the whales perspective.
Yeah, I saw that.
So that was pretty cool.
So I'm hoping that we have more meetups,
because when you have a spotter, it's easier.
I actually didn't see him
in the air and hopefully we can start
to coordinate because then you can actually
maybe look under and see something, but--
You need some kind of waterproof earpiece
where he can direct you
where to swim, get right on top of the whale.
Well, you're not supposed to do that, right.
So you're not supposed to, if you see a whale out there
or even dolphins, you're not supposed to get in their way,
you're not supposed to intentionally swim there.
So what we do is we swim there anyway.
As anyone can tell, we swim all year round there.
And so when they come around,
they have to come to you or you have to just get lucky
and stumble upon them and then it's fine.
And we're not doing anything.
We never touch them, we never do anything.
We don't even get that close, why would you?
And so I feel like it's pretty good
and we're not, we're never in their way.
So it's nice when it's more accidental,
but at the same time, when you're a floating head,
you can't even see where you are.
So if it's, it could be 20 feet away
from you and you miss it, especially if there's some motion
on the surface.
So it's nice to be able to have a friend like
the Malibu artist who does some epic videos.
That's pretty cool.
Let's do a quick obit for your man, Jack Kerouac,
who probably never lapsed
into any kind of dadism at any point.
No.
In his life.
His niece is a listener of yours.
Oh really?
His great niece is a listener of yours.
And she followed me and then we had a little back and forth.
She's a photographer and we had a back and forth.
I said, "Kerouac, interesting."
And it's her great uncle.
Amazing.
Yeah and I said, this is the greatest, this is,
I was so touched and yeah, so she's a listener.
And he just turned 100, he died at 47.
But to me he's obviously,
that's where we got the holy inside milk from.
That's kind of where I cribbed it from, one
of his, I believe that came from "Mexico City Blues,"
one of his poems.
And that's probably his best poetry compilation.
I'm still "On the Road," the Seminal work.
I love that one, I also love "Dharma Bums."
I love all that whole entire four-part book series
"On the Road," "Subterranean,"
"Dharma Bums," and "Big Sur,"
which is the saddest one, but it's still great.
And I'm a writer because of Jack Kerouac.
I think I might have said that before on here,
because he opened up a whole world in an ecstatic way.
It's literary, but in
an ecstatic, open, explorative, exploratory way.
And so I just always really fell
right into the rhythm of his work
and that's why I wanted to wander and travel.
So it's his fault, mom and dad, it's Jack Kerouac's fault.
Well, happy birthday, Jack.
Yeah, I remember reading "On the Road"
when I was driving cross country one year,
when I was probably 20.
That's the time.
And yeah, where anything is possible and the world
is a vast and glorious canvas for self-exploration.
Yeah, and I mean,
the book is about hitchhiking across America.
It takes place in, right after World War II
is when he actually did it.
Didn't come out, he wrote it
in three weeks on benzedrine, like a speed haze.
He was a good alcoholic.
He was.
And then he, that took seven years for it to come out.
And it was an overnight smash hit and he was dismissed.
People in the literary world were dismissive
of him, I guess, sometime later, I don't know.
But I don't really have much.
The literary world is its own little insular place
and to me it doesn't mean much.
A guy like Jack Kerouac kind of transcends all of that.
And so if you haven't read any
of his stuff, if you're a 20-year-old
that wants to get out and look around-
That's the time.
I highly recommend
checking it out.
Means a lot to people of a certain generation.
Cool, man.
So what's next?
What about you Rich?
What's going on with you?
I feel grateful today, I'm happy to be here with you.
It's been a couple weeks, Adam, so that's all good.
I'm a little fatigued, it's been an intense last week.
Last week I did three podcasts or in the last seven days,
three podcasts, two back-to-back speaking gigs.
So I'm a little ragged, but feeling good.
In town or were you.
Well, one was down in Palos Verdes.
So I was overnight in one place
and did a speaking thing that was late
at night, and then had one on Zoom the following my morning
at like seven o'clock in the morning.
So it's all good, but it takes a little bit of a toll.
I did wanna thank you
for introducing us to your friend Oz Pearlman.
'Cause he came in and did a podcast the other day.
Oz, for people who don't know, is a mentalist,
he was a finalist on "America's Got Talent," back
in 2015, and he just absolutely blew people's minds.
It was really fun, I can't wait
to share that episode and I'm not gonna spoil it other
than to say, we're still talking about it.
Like everyone here at the show is like,
and he did this and then this happened
and it was unbelievable.
I mean, the guy is a straight up wizard.
Yes.
Oh my God.
(man clapping)
It's not even a common name.
Rich is like, I'm gonna watch this thing a million times.
I'm gonna figure this out.
I'm gonna get the bottom of this shit.
Jason just believes in real magic.
He's like, I don't know if you know this,
but we got Harry Potter in the house right now.
He turns grownups, serious grownups
into like shrieking school children.
I know, it's like I think he,
I think John Cena threw a book
at him or something like that on "The Today Show."
He was so outraged at...
He seems to have that kind of effect on people.
I mean, it really is remarkable.
And on top of it, he's this incredible Ultrarunner.
Amazing.
He's done all
the big races from Badwater to Western States,
he's a 2:23 marathoner, so a super interesting guy.
He cracks open minds and like--
How did you meet him?
Or what was the point of interaction?
So he had a regular live show happening,
I think in New York City.
And he couldn't do in-person stuff
at the beginning of the pandemic.
And he's friends with David and so then David--
He knows David from way back,
early endurance for Ultra running.
Right, right, right.
So they're tight, and so David
and Jennifer organized a crew of their people to do a Zoom.
Oh, cool.
And basically
David hired him to do this Zoom.
And so he, and then he invited people.
So then he invited us to be a part of that.
And so we went on this Zoom and saw it.
But I'd heard of him before.
So I knew of him 'cause I'd seen him on ESPN.
He did, like there was a period
of time where ESPN had him on for like a couple of days
and he visited all the shows and did some fun stuff.
And so I'd heard of him, I'd seen him before,
and he was fun, but seeing it
in person and getting really personal with people,
you just like that brought it to a different level.
And then following him
and seeing how great he was as an athlete.
I realized, now this is a different,
I didn't really understand who he was.
And so ever since then, I've been kind
of chatting with him here and there.
I wanna cover him, at some point.
Yeah, you should.
I've been trying to get,
to figure out the right thing for the times.
And so it'll happen.
But in the meantime,
he loves your show and wanted to be here so bad.
So it was cool to get him in here.
Yeah, we had a great time, it was super fun.
Speaking of being an athlete,
technically I'm meant to be training right now,
but the training's been--
Yes, what's going on?
Very erratic and disrupted due to my work schedule
and kind of family schedule.
I signed up for this open water marathon swim in June.
So you did sign up for it?
20 kilometer, 20 kilometer.
We'll just leave it at that.
20 kilometer, open water swim race, just like 12 miles.
That's no joke.
I haven't swam more
than 3,500 yard, I mean, today I did 4,000,
but that's probably the longest swim
I've put in a couple years.
So I have my work cut out for me.
So was that a 4,000 straight?
You did a 4,000?
No, in the pool, it's always intervals
and sets, and things like that.
I'm working with Chris Hauth again.
And it's a challenge because I don't like
to be unprepared at all for any kind
of race, but my life is very complicated right now.
So it's about like making peace
with the fact that I'm not gonna be able
to adhere to the training schedule like I used to,
when my life was a little less crowded.
So we'll see how to that goes.
But Chris had a great idea, which was for us to do a Zoom,
like a little segment on upcoming "Roll Ons,"
where Chris and I do a Zoom and we check in on the training.
So it's sort of a peak behind the curtain
on like how we communicate, how all
of this works, and maybe hopefully that's instructive
or helpful for the other athletes out there,
who are trying to figure out
how to train for races, amidst the distractions
and other obligations of our busy lives.
I love that.
So we'll figure that out.
So perhaps next "Roll On," Chris will pop in.
I need, Chris's tough love in my life.
I know, but he, Chris is, he's softened up a little bit.
We're gonna talk a little bit about
that with respect to Jesse Itzler, 'cause I wanna talk
about his Ultraman Arizona performance this past weekend.
But before we do that, in terms
of like how I'm doing and what's going on right now,
despite everything being great, and me being grateful
and happy to be sitting with you here today,
I'm a little bit distracted and fatigued.
I haven't been sleeping great because on a family level,
we're dealing with a little bit of psychic pain
that has been challenging and leaving me hard-pressed
to think about anything else, because our youngest kid
had his heart broken over the weekend.
He was very intense upon getting
into this cinema arts program
at LA's Performing Arts High School.
And it's a big public high school,
he's going into ninth grade.
And part of that application process was writing,
and directing and editing a short film, which he did.
And he made a remarkable film by all accounts.
Everybody who saw it said, "This is unbelievable."
And his older sister goes
to this school currently as a senior.
And so we thought we were in pretty good shape
for him to be accepted into this program.
And we found out that he was not accepted,
that it didn't work out the way
that we all had hoped for him.
And it's been more than disappointing, like he's devastated.
And so the reason I bring it up, I try,
I keep my kids out of the podcast
and I don't wanna get too detailed
about that situation,
other than to say, it's been a challenge as a parent
trying to figure out how to show up as a compassionate dad.
And I can't think of anything more difficult
than kind of holding that level of psychic
and emotional pain that your child is going through.
It's a sense of powerlessness.
Like, I've been a parent for a minute
and this has definitely been one of the hardest chapters
in this journey that I've been on as a dad.
And it's just, it's like
you can feel all that pain and you can empathize
with it and you try to hold space
for them, but you can't alleviate it for them.
And it's hard, man.
And I think for me, I have a pattern,
like an unhealthy pattern of projecting onto my kid.
And that's a pattern that I learned
as a child because that's what my mother would do.
Projecting how?
Like, oh, it's so, oh, how are you?
And like sort of in a weird kind
of enmeshing way, like I've grown a lot.
Like I don't, I'm very conscious
of not doing that and like making the problem worse
by saying, "Oh, we're all so disappointed for you."
Like, it doesn't help.
Like, how can you be solid
and strong, and compassionate and available.
And a dad that is signaling to their kid,
like I got your back, we're gonna figure this out.
And this is a setback, but we have a plan for you
and we're gonna see this through,
and we're gonna get through it together
without becoming too, like reducing your emotional state
to that of the child as a way of connecting.
Thinking that you're validating their emotion.
Yeah 'cause it comes from a good place.
By joining into the emotion.
Right, but that's not a healthy strategy for that.
So it's like learning how to check myself.
And it's been really hard.
And I have to say that it has led me to turn back
to the wisdom of past podcast guest, like Susan David,
who writes and talks about emotional agility
and Jessica Lahey, in her book, "The Gift of Failure,"
like this idea that
these experiences cultivate emotional agility.
But this is a kid who really needed a win.
The pandemic has been very rough
on him and this was a North Star
and it got like pulled out from underneath him.
After doing great work.
At that age it's traumatic, right?
And to see your kid in the midst of a trauma is just,
it's very difficult.
I'm sorry.
So that's kind of going on in the background.
So if I start to space out
in this podcast, it's probably 'cause I'm--
I'll take care of it, I'll handle it.
Dwelling on that in an unhealthy way.
You know, and it's like allowing your kid
to experience their painful emotions is necessary.
But as a parent, it's also like a form of psychic torture.
No parent wants to see their child in pain.
No, isn't that the worst, isn't that the hardest thing
is to see your child hurting.
Really hard, really hard.
So that's what you have to look forward to, Adam.
So it gets more complicated is what you're saying?
Yes.
Yes it does, it definitely does.
So when, so, but even like
in this situation, when you first learn
about it, you can't even get to the point, we have a plan
for you, we're gonna see this through, it's a setback.
You can't even really say anything, right?
No, you have to allow them to experience their emotions.
You have to let the pain come through.
And not be the person who's like trying
to get them over it too quickly, or--
Or shield them.
Yeah, but also make sure
that they're not shutting down too much.
It's this weird balance.
And as a dad, like what is the healthy,
kind of masculinity that you can model
and be of maximum support
without being like a hard ass or too much of a softy?
Right, what's the right amount of stoicism?
Right, like, and also knowing
that they don't wanna hear it from you, right?
No, your opinion does not matter.
It's like, we're gonna get over this.
You're gonna look back on this
and realize like that you found yourself in a better...
None of that works right now.
It's like, so just having their back
I think is the key thing.
So anyway, that's going on, but let's switch gears.
Let's do it.
To a very exciting, positive note.
It's a big day here at "Roll On."
We have a big announcement,
which is that "Voicing Change II" is now out.
Yes.
And available.
I've been looking forward to this thing.
Yeah, check it out in the box.
It comes in this like really cool pizza box, basically.
And when you open it up, let me see if I can open this.
Has a beautiful, like ribbon here, it pulls it out.
And here we go.
So for people that are kind of newer to the show
and don't know what we're talking about, there it is, Adam.
A little over a year ago, we released volume one,
of "Voicing Change,"
which is this black book that you see here.
And it's essentially this compendium of the best wisdom
and guests of the podcast
over the course of several years in coffee table book form.
And we self-published it, it was a success,
it's filled with like gorgeous photography and excerpts.
We go through the transcripts of all of these guest podcasts
and we excerpt out the best parts,
and I write an introduction.
And we have essays littered throughout it.
And we're really proud of it.
And it works as a great introduction to the podcast
for people who are unfamiliar with the work that we do here,
it's kind of a keepsake for the fans, it's an awesome gift.
But when we created the first "Voicing Change,"
it was always intended
as part one and what would be a series.
And so today, a little over a year later,
we are announcing volume two,
which picks up where volume one left off, of course.
And it's even better than the first one.
It's 288 pages of episode excerpts, we have essays.
We have stunning photos, 64 guests are featured.
And what can I tell you?
Who are some of the people in here?
We have Matthew McConaughey, Tony Hawk, Dr. Huberman,
Maggie Q, Steven Pressfield, Alexi Pappas,
The Korean Vegan, tons of cool people.
And of course, Adam, you were featured in this book.
I made the cut?
There's a whole "Roll On" thing in here.
There's a whole "Roll On."
And Adam, you wrote it.
You contributed an essay to the book.
I think there's a "Roll On" centerfold in that thing.
Let me find it.
You know what, it was when you guys approached me
and asked me to be a part of this thing, I was so touched.
And I love these books
because it's the way into the show.
Like, it's a great-- (laughter)
We have like several pages on "Roll On" in this book.
We do, you wrote something about it too.
Right.
But it took me writing that
to realize that your podcast is why I'm married to April.
(laughs) I'd forgotten.
I'd forgotten.
Explain that.
Well, I mean, I wrote
in the essay, what I loved
about the essay is because it allowed me to reflect back
on being a part of this team and being a part of your show.
And for a long time,
I was just an independent reporter out there,
kind of hacking my way through the wilderness.
And I liked those years too, but it's not easy.
And you always kind of wish,
what would it be like if you were part of a team,
if you were a part of a newsroom, you always wonder.
Even the days when I was doing
the Lonely Planet travel guides,
there were fellow authors I sometimes ran into on the road,
but it's pretty much an independent job.
You're out there by yourself.
It's designed so that you work independently together.
So you're not really crossing paths
unless you go outta your way.
And even though you can email and there's some comradery,
it's quite the same as coming into an environment like this,
where you have real collaboration and real teamwork,
and so on a regular basis, consistent basis.
So it's been such a welcome thing for me,
and also to get into the audio side on a different way
from just audio books, to the podcast space,
it was always great, but I never had a chance
to really sit back and analyze it,
or consider what made it special for me.
So this essay was an opportunity
to do that, to consider the show, what the show is,
why it's unique, why the audience is unique, to be part
of this, which includes, when I say collaboration,
I include the audience as part of that because
what's special about a lot of podcasts,
but particularly your podcast
is that people are very personally connected to it.
Because there's an individual aspect.
There's a social good aspect.
It's inwardly focused with an outward viewpoint,
an expansive viewpoint, and it's a seed bank and toolbox
to be able to kind of tinker with your world
and the greater larger world, and try to make it better.
So it's kind of like this real time dreaming
of a different way of going, and at the same time,
taking gratitude in what's happening.
So that I always knew,
but to be part of it and to experience it from the inside
has been really enlightening for me, because like,
I'm typically kind of happy being a little gloom and doomed
to be quite honest with you, like the light of the show.
Very uncomfortable for you.
Yeah, no, it's (laughs)
the light of your show is now changing me.
Now I'm saying things like, "Rock and roll, crew."
And that's not your fault.
So anyway, I fun to write the essay
and really an honor to explain.
And part of that is, yes, after being on your podcast,
when I was promoting "One Breath," April listened
to it, we had known each other a little bit before
that and reached out, we got reconnected and then voila.
And that was it.
So that's all part of that story
that I kind of tell in this.
And in general, I love the book because it is a way in,
so if you're a fan and you wanna introduce people
to the podcast, but it's a heavy lift to get them
to listen to two and a half hours of me bothering Rich,
then you can give them this "Voicing Change,"
and you can check out some of these cool guests.
And you can read and a couple of the features,
and they'll understand why you like it so much.
And it's kind of a way into the show in a different way.
It's a 288-page visual blinkest.
That's it.
You said it.
A synopsis.
I love it.
With cool photographs and...
Yeah, well said, I appreciate that.
It's been such a fun journey
and an honor to do this thing with you.
And it's cool that people are digging
and it's grown, and now you're part of the firmament.
I'm here.
You're in the wallpaper now.
You can't get rid of me now.
I know.
I don't know what, now it's like,
what would happen if we didn't wanna do this anymore?
I don't know.
I would show up at your doorstep.
I would be sleeping where Jason's working right now.
Great.
(both chuckling)
Anyway, thank you for generously providing that essay
and there's a bunch more essays in it.
The book is beautiful.
I think it's even better than the last one.
It's really been a team effort.
Like I certainly didn't,
I probably worked the least on this book.
We have this amazing group of people
of craftsmen, very talented people who we collaborated
with to create this wonderful work of art.
And it's just an exciting moment
to be able to now share it with everybody.
So to sweeten it, we came up with this really cool idea
to do what we're calling a golden ticket sweepstake.
So basically to celebrate this launch and do something cool
and unique and meaningful,
we came up with essentially a contest,
which will entitle six lucky winners
to receive, we'll get like a golden ticket in the book.
And do we have, I don't know
if we have one of the golden tickets printed out, do we?
I don't think we do.
So like a Willy Wonka thing.
It's a Willy Wonka thing and basically the winners
will get this treasure chest
of prizes that have been gifted from our amazing sponsors
that include like a pair of Solomon Ultra Glide shoes
and Athletic Green Starter kits.
A pair of Roca glasses,
a pair of Jaybird Vista 2 earbuds, a Theragon,
a one year membership to the plant power meal planner,
all told it's basically an $1,100 value.
And so to win, there's a couple ways to win.
Obviously buying a copy of "Voicing Change II"
automatically enters you to win.
But also importantly, I need to point out
that there is also a no purchase necessary option,
terms and conditions apply.
So if you wanna learn more
about the rules behind the golden ticket offering,
go to Richroll.com/official-rules for more details.
Can I say, can interject one thing?
Yeah.
I think you only have five Theragon elites left.
What do you mean?
Did you steal one?
I don't know.
Did you take one from our stash?
I saw box of them, I didn't think you'd miss them.
Come on, man.
All right, I'll return it.
We need that one back.
Yeah, it's coming back.
All right, like I said, the book is self-published.
We do everything in house, it was this amazing team effort.
And for that reason, we are offering the book only
and exclusively on our website at richroll.com.
It's not available on Amazon.
So to learn more about it and pick up your copy,
go to richroll.com/books.
We only did a limited print,
so it's not gonna be available forever.
So you're gonna have to act now if you wanna get it.
And final note.
I think "Voicing Change I" sold out.
Yeah, I think we have a few left,
but "Voicing Change II"
is what we're focusing on right now.
And we have plenty of copies,
but I think they're gonna go fast.
If, how "Voicing Change II" went,
they're gonna go quick.
One thing I wanted to point out with "Voicing Change I,"
there was some complaints and grumpyness around shipping
because we're self-publishing
and self-fulfilling, and all of that, and not on Amazon.
Shipping becomes very tricky.
Anybody who sells product can understand that.
And I wanna just tell everyone that we heard you
with respect to those complaints.
So for this book, "Voicing Change II,"
we have flat rate $10 shipping domestically.
It probably costs us more in most cases.
So we're just gonna eat that extra surcharge
because we wanted to make it available
across the board at one rate for everybody.
And we're gonna have just,
we have discounted shipping internationally.
Perfect.
So we have heard those that feedback
and we're doing the best that we can to address that.
Right, I mean, not everybody has a rocket ship
and Pete Davidson just deliver their boxes
to their front door, okay?
That's true, what happened at the Amazon drones?
That program never took off.
That's in beta, bro.
We were gonna be able
to order pizzas and have them dropped off on our doorstep.
Yes, dropped off by Roombas.
Cool, so yes, "Voicing Change II."
One more thing before we take a quick break,
I wanted to direct everyone's attention
to my friend, Heidi Zuckerman's new book, it's called
"Conversations with Artists Three,"
Heidi's an old friend of mine from the New York City days.
I used to date her sister when I lived there
and she is an amazing.
Rich is just kids, just kids chapter.
Yeah, that's right kind of, not quite,
but a little bit maybe,
but I've known Heidi for a very long time.
And she's sort of a big deal in the art world.
When I knew her, she was a young gallerist,
but she has gone on to have posts at the UC Berkeley Museum
of Art, the Jewish Museum in New York city.
More recently, she was the director of the Aspen Art Museum,
where she did all this really cool, innovative stuff.
She oversaw the construction of the new building there
by this famed architect Shigeru Ban.
And she did this thing where she had top artists
create artwork printed on the lift tickets,
which I thought was very innovative and cool.
And so basically she's become
one of the leading museum directors in the United States
and left Aspen in 2019
and is now in California, where she is the new Director
of the Orange County Museum of Art.
Where they're building this massive new building
that I think is pretty close
to being completed at this point.
Where is that?
Is that in Santa Ana or something?
I think it's in, where is it?
Long Beach?
No, I don't think it's in Long Beach.
I think it's in.
Orange or something.
San Clemente or something like that.
San Clemente.
I don't know exactly but
the building is designed by Thom Mayne,
who's a legendary kind of modern architect.
He was the mentor to the architect that built our house.
So in any event.
Santa Ana.
In Santa Ana cool.
So Heidi, when she left Aspen, she started this kind
of digital platform that included a podcast conversations
about art, which I was a guest on,
along with people like Ricky Gates and Eve Bahar.
She had Rufus Wainwright on, Tom Sachs and Lance Armstrong.
And then she published the series of books,
which are kind of an analog to "Voicing Change"
in that they're excerpts from her conversations
with these many artists over the years.
And this is her volume three.
So she's one volume ahead of us.
Oh God.
On this same kind of plane,
turning the best of what a podcast offers into a book form.
She shares insights and access
to some of the world's most engaging artists.
And in this book, what, who does she,
I mean, Tom Sachs is in here, he is one of my favorites.
Doug Akin, Daniel Arsham, Sam Falls,
Jennifer Guidy, Glen Kino.
Anyway, it's a cool book.
I love Heidi, she's a really interesting person,
perhaps she'd make a great guest on this podcast.
Nice.
So if you wanna check out that book, it is only available
on the Orange County Museum of Art website.
So go to amaocma.art/pop-up,
and I'll link that up in the show notes.
Beautiful.
Cool, so let's take a quick break and we'll be back.
We're gonna talk about Jesse Itzler's Ultraman
and we're gonna solve Ukraine basically.
We're solving Ukraine.
We're gonna solve it.
We, you and me?
Yeah, we solved it already.
Yeah, well we can solve it.
All right.
Prophets walk among us,
(gentle music)
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people, who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling prophets
on the planet, going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book, "Voicing Change Volume Two,"
more than mere words on paper.
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation
of the magic, inspiration and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on the Rich Roll Podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was a beautifully rendered book worthy
of display on any coffee table, and volume two follows
in that tradition by showcasing even more
of my favorite conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography, making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume or a satisfying standalone work.
And every copy comes with
a chance of winning our golden ticket sweepstakes.
Six golden tickets will be hidden
within a handful of books and will unlock a treasure chest
of cool gifts donated by several of our sponsors.
See official rules for details.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained with it.
"Voicing Change Volume Two" available now
while supplies last for a limited time,
order your copy today only at richroll.com.
All right, and we're back.
We're gonna talk about Jesse Itzler Ultraman Arizona.
This is my favorite story from the weekend,
perhaps the best Instagram stories on the entire platform.
The past couple days for those that are unfamiliar,
Jesse's a friend, a two time podcast guest,
one of the founders of 29029, that Everesting challenge.
He's a amazing entrepreneur
and a very kind of inspiring individual.
And his whole thing is about like building your life resume
and like making the most out of your day.
And he's got this big calendar
and he calendars out all his goals
and his dreams, and he shares everything on Instagram
and he just has a very beautiful infectious energy.
And he signed up for Ultraman Arizona.
He'd never done an Ultraman before,
but he's done some hundred miles.
And he is an experienced ultra runner,
but what made this great,
in addition to the fact that he's 54 years old,
is that he showed up to compete
in this race with ostensibly doing no training.
None at all, just his normal.
I mean, he gets out there and he's very active
and he's running and riding his bike or whatever,
but there was no structure at all to his training.
And like Ultraman is a double Ironman distance triathlon,
it's 320 miles.
Day one is a 6.2 mile swim and a 90-mile bike.
The second day is 171 miles on the bike.
The third day is a double marathon.
People who know my story know that I've done this race
in Hawaii a couple times.
And so I was very invested
in seeing how this was gonna play out.
I bet.
Given that
he hadn't really trained,
but he is somebody who never gives up also.
So that tension between
being physically unprepared for this.
Right.
With the strong mental game of like, I don't quit,
makes for a very interesting tableau for storytelling.
Right for sure.
It didn't disappoint.
So Blake, can you pull up Chris's,
this tab that I have for Chris Heath
who was helping Jesse as well.
And of course is my coach posted this on Instagram.
I think the day before the morning
of the race, where it's just a handwritten note.
If you're watching on video, you can see it,
but I'll read it like Jesse's says to Chris,
"Chris, you think I should do Ultraman Arizona.
I haven't trained, Chris.
I think taking the unconventional bat
has served you well so far in life.
Why have your athletics self be different?"
And then Jesse says, or Chris says,
"Where is the greater adventure being prepared,
familiar and doing it,
or being unprepared in uncharted territory
and being on the edge."
So that's the kind of context
in which Jesse towed the start line at this crazy race,
not a conventional quest from an athlete perspective,
but I think there's something cool about him
as Chris knows, it's choosing to step into the arena
only with past endurance experience, a strong mind,
a willingness to endure, and a strong support team.
What's interesting about this whole thing.
I mean, obviously the double marathon is super intense
and long days on the bike, I mean a 171 miles, no joke,
but a 6.2 mile swim, if you don't swim.
Like that might be the hardest one.
Well, here's what happens.
so basically they show up,
it starts on Friday morning
and there was so much wind, you know 'cause you were out
in the desert, it was super windy
in LA, I guess it was windy in Arizona as well.
So there was tons of swell and chop, they started to swim.
I think the water was like 57 degrees, so not warm.
No.
Jesse's got like.
They have a suit or wherever-
He's got like a full suit with,
he's got the mits and the booties and the whole thing.
And like, and they start to swim,
but they soon realize like this is not a safe situation
and they call off the swim.
When I think there are maybe a kilometer,
a kilometer or a half into it.
But Jesse was like, they had to change it from,
I think what was a point
to point to a loop, so that they could monitor everything.
And then after the first loop, they're like, we're done.
But Jesse had already started his second loop
and wasn't aware that they called it.
And so there was all this chaos trying
to find him and get him out and then they got everybody out
and then they just said, "All right, you have one hour
and we're gonna start the bike portion."
So they didn't end up swimming 6.2 miles.
So I suppose there's a bit of an asterisk on all of this.
Because yeah, 6.2 mile swim,
if you don't have a competitive swimming background
is like not a joke.
And I think that threat distinguishes Ultraman
from typical triathlons that cater to the non-swimmer
like this one, you actually really have to have-
Yes.
An ability there and it can be meaningful in terms of
whether you're gonna finish the race or not, or how well.
Well, 'cause you also, you would get seasick,
like I've talked to many open water swimmers.
I mean, it's almost like a guarantee that if you're not used
to it, you will throw up at some point,
which impacts the beginning of your bike ride.
Right, so Jesse who doesn't have a background
in swimming was spared a little bit of that, I suppose.
But the drama continued.
It's a long enough race where everyone.
He made through the 90-mile bike
on day one, he looked a little bit beat up,
but in okay shape after that.
But the day two, a 171 mile bike almost buried him
and he had to make it,
there's they have time cutoffs, right?
So he basically just wanted
to like finish before the time cutoff.
And he was successful in that, he with 15 minutes to spare.
So he got there.
He was touch and go and there were tons of headwinds.
And I think on the second day,
there's something like 8,000 feet of climbing.
So crazy.
A challenging ride and he gets it done
and he just looked like hell.
I was like, "Oh, that poor guy, man," he couldn't walk.
I mean, he was pretty banged up.
And then on day three,
his ankle looked look like the size of a grapefruit.
Before, starting?
Before starting the run.
Geez.
And he suffered through it and finished that run,
which had a 12 hour cutoff, like with 23 minutes to spare.
So 1137, so he completed it, I wonder
if his, some of these Instagram stories are still up here,
the volume on that.
I guess some of them are here, you can see him.
He's in pretty bad shape.
Yeah.
His ankle beforehand.
That was at the end, so anyway, these will be gone off
of Instagram stories by the time this podcast goes up.
But for anybody who went along for the journey, like I was.
Maybe he'll save it.
Maybe he'll save it in one of these.
I'm sure they'll make some videos out of this.
There he is, here he is crossing the finish line.
He's trying to run to it.
He can't even run to it.
I know.
Well, I mean.
But he did it, man.
He made it, there must be so much pain there.
Yeah, the race is so much harder
than the numbers on a piece of paper.
It really is a brutal race.
And I'd love to have him back on the pot podcast
and share what this journey was all about.
You got to, that'll be a fun one.
It's cool, so congrats to Jesse, we love you.
And I love how it was all shared
so transparently on social media.
I think that's very inspiring
for a lot of people, which is really Jesse's greatest gift.
Like he has this ability
to get people enthusiastic about doing hard things.
And he does that by modeling it in his own life.
Perfect.
So are we gonna get to the hard stuff now?
You mean the existential crises,
the dueling existential crises of our time?
Explain.
The light news of the world,
the Ukraine and apocalyptic flooding in Australia.
Right, climate change versus nuclear annihilation.
Well, a wink at nuclear annihilation, it's just a wink.
A throw away smile at nuclear annihilation.
What are your thoughts, Adam?
My thoughts.
I mean, I think people are more interested
in what you were thinking as this was unfolding,
but my thoughts were
kind of in disbelief, I think as it unfolded,
when it first started happening, I thought, okay,
just like everybody else, this will be quick.
It'll be over quickly and it's sad.
And but it won't take long
'cause I thought Russia's military might
and all that, like everybody else.
And then I started to see these pictures
of these old grizzled vets kind
of lining up to sign up for the army and I started seeing
signs of at like the gritty Ukrainian people
and how they were feeling about it
and what they were gonna do.
And then I thought, wait a second,
this might not be so easy.
But at the same time,
when I was worried that if it was easy,
it wouldn't just be Ukraine,
'cause he was starting
to talk about Scandinavia and he was starting to talk
about other places and kind of daring us to get involved.
And then bringing up the nuclear weapons.
And so like everyone else,
I thought this could be World War III.
I really did think that it could,
what happens if China decides
to move on Taiwan and all of this?
Like where does this all go?
And so I was very highly concerned
about the potential for World War III.
And so that's how it started for me, how about you?
Yeah, I would share that.
I mean I'm certainly no geopolitical expert
and I don't know that I have a take,
that's gonna be any different
from anybody who's paying attention to what's going on,
but I can share my devastation at this unprovoked aggression
that's sacrificing lives.
It's surreal that in 2022,
one human being like this dictator,
who's clearly not operating on a completely rational plane
can wreak so much havoc and devastation on the world
by dint of like an ego that's out of control.
And we're in a very precarious place
that reminds me of what it was like back in the early '80s,
when I was a kid, I mean I'm old enough
to have lived through a significant portion of the Cold War
as a kid growing up in Washington DC,
where basically politics is all anybody talks about.
And it feels similar to that, like this inching towards
an increasingly more alerted DEFCON status
and a guy who has his finger on a button
that could cause unimaginable damage.
It's frighting, it's scary.
And so I think the fear is real.
I mean, for Gen Xers,
it brings us back to "War Games" and like "Red Dawn"
and all these kind of seminal kind of like "Rocky IV"
and like every the Soviet Union and all of that.
And for people older than us,
it goes back to the Cuban missile crisis and all of that.
And so it was right away that's what you're thinking.
And then out of that comes this other story,
that's more like "300," like the Ukrainian people rising up
and proving that actually Russia,
doesn't have the best military that you might think.
They have a lot of firepower and it's proving out now
as they're hammering Kyiv today,
but they aren't necessarily the machine that we feared.
Sure, to your first point
in the list of movies that you just spoke about.
The one for me is "The Day After."
Right that one.
So this is a Gen X staple, like you're my age
like I remember seeing "The Day After,"
I was probably in ninth or 10th grade.
I think it was 1983 when that movie came out,
which is a chronicle of the weeks leading up
to and following a nuclear strike
in Kansas, it had like John Lithgow in it and Jason Robards
and this movie was seen by 100 million people
during its initial broadcast.
And it was traumatic for me because you essentially see
nuclear devastation and like how this plays out.
And I was shookk by that,
and I still think about that movie because I was
at that age where I was very impressionable,
and this was kind of going on in current events.
So I felt very like real and visceral.
And so yeah, that this what's going
on now kind of evokes that memory on some level,
but it is true like this idea that Russia was gonna go in
and in two or three days take Kyiv
that Zelenskyy would flee
and they'd install their puppet government.
And of course that's not what has happened.
And we've seen, the world has born witness to this guy,
I mean, the story of Zelenskyy is unbelievable.
Unbelievably.
Like him kind of shouldering the mantle
of leadership in a way that perhaps nobody predicted
and the resilience and determination of the Ukrainian people
to fight for their country has been remarkable to witness.
And in juxtaposition to a Russian armed force
that it's kind of unprepared, like I think.
Unprepared.
Lots of them weren't even told what they were doing.
Like this was some kind of military exercise.
And even in Russia now you can't talk about it being a war.
Like that's not how it's characterized and we can talk
about the information war that's going on
in the propaganda within the boundaries of Russia.
But I think the Russian forces were quite surprised
to meet the resistance that they've met.
And I don't know what the will of the Russian armed forces
is to withstand that kind of defense.
Well, unprepared and underfunded
and under supplied as well.
I mean their 18 year old kids,
who have three days of training and a Kalashnikov.
And eating 10 year olds MREs that were expired.
The video of the MREs
that expired in 2015 is a window into what's actually going
on in Russia versus what Putin would like us to believe.
The truth is Russia's GDP is the size of Spain.
That's not a criticism of Spain or anything like that,
but it's not like they are this great power economically,
which is why this is happening, right?
'Cause Ukraine has, is a great power.
So Russia is very rich in natural resources,
but Ukraine has figured out a way to serve the technological
space that the tech space they've got,
minerals that are poised to help in this new energy economy
that's emerging.
Whereas Russia has the stuff of the old energy economy.
Ukraine has combined with Russia,
a third of the wheat is supplied world globally
is supplied from Ukraine.
I think a third of EU wheat just comes from Ukraine alone.
And then Russia and Ukraine combines
a third of the entire global wheat supply.
So Ukraine is very strategic.
There's a reason he's going after Ukraine.
There is not an easy way out of Ukraine.
So that's to your point
of saying like how gritty, how incredible these people are
and Zelenskyy as a leader who is Churchillian I remember
during the summer of 2020 and 2021, you couldn't even,
Churchill was on the verge
of getting canceled and now we're
using Churchillian to describe Zelenskyy and rightfully so.
And Biden is being criticized as being more Chamberlinean.
But he's not really though.
I mean, Chamberlain was like
meeting and hanging out with Hitler
and that's not what Biden is doing.
No, but of course, I mean I think
also to the point of being Gen X,
I'm used to, and grew up in an era where
whenever the United States found itself
in some kind of conflict, it would be the Republicans
in their hawkish disposition saying
that the Democrats aren't acting swiftly enough,
we need to be more aggressive.
We need to basically ramp up the military.
And what we're seeing now is a mirror image
of that, this weird inversion of that,
where the administration is trying to figure out
the appropriate responses that's not gonna overly
incite Russia to do something rash.
Where is that balance and we can have a conversation
around that and what that might look like
and whether or not they're succeeding at that.
But it is bizarre to see certain facets
of the Republican party or the Alt-right
kind of detouring into ostensibly like Putin apology.
It's absolutely nuts, it's absolutely nuts.
Like the most anti-Soviet people were always the Republicans
Reagan made a living off of it,
Bush two and the Bush one as well.
The military industrial complex was built off the back
of being against Russia.
Right and so 100% percent.
And then you look at it and at first I think the Republicans
have switched their tune now, I think they're going.
But those people have kind of gone silent.
They've gone silent, but at first you had Tucker Carlson,
like they basically saying,
"What has Putin done that's so bad."
He's never done anything to me.
He's never called me a racist.
And this idea, like the fandom
of him because of anti-wokism
or whatever, is just, is a very strange thing.
Like this model of toxic masculinity that is
so attractive for a certain archetype of person is bizarre.
And yeah, that whole sentiment has kind of gone dark
because the world is united
in support of Ukraine right now.
And it's pretty obvious that Putin's out of control.
And when was the last time that the entire EU
like agreed on any one singular thing?
Like sanctions being essentially
a unanimous strategic weapon at the moment.
That's interesting.
Two things I wanted to bring up.
You said toxic masculinity, I'd like to a point out
that Vladimir Putin rides a tricycle, a motorized tricycle.
This has been my mission as soon as the invasion started,
I've been telling everyone I wanna make it very clear.
Google it, Vladimir Putin rides a tricycle.
I haven't seen it.
He's a grown up man, who rides a tricycle, there you go.
And maybe that's why he's invading Ukraine,
the second thing is that I noticed
at the beginning was like, how fragile it all is.
That's what I also thought of because.
Well, that's what makes it so terrifying.
Right, 'cause I have a friend De Negro Mary
his a great free diver based out
of Tahiti, but he was training
in Egypt and then he stopped in saw friends
in Kyiv about three weeks before all this happened.
And he was literally going out bowling.
I was talking to him on the phone.
He was bowling with his friends, having drinks
in Kyiv and saying what a wonderful city it is.
And like, they were all like carefree.
Like, I mean, they were chilling
and then three weeks later everyone's terrified
the whole place is falling apart.
It just shows you how fragile, like what would happen to us?
How fragile is our situation?
It's all so fragile.
Much more fragile than we think.
Yes.
Of course.
Yeah.
Right?
This is the first legitimate war armed conflict
that is playing out on social media.
So I wanna talk about the information aspects of that.
'Cause I find that fascinating, but before we do that,
can we just talk a minute
about like the kind of meta simulation theory quality
to all of this as well, starting with Zelenskyy.
Yes.
I mean, it's unbelievable.
Volodymyr Zelenskyy.
This guy comedian, actor.
He was on "Dancing with the Stars."
I mean, he's certainly a showman,
but the meta nature of his career trajectory is fascinating
in that he's this guy who created this sitcom
that he starred in, where he's a high school teacher
who goes on a political rant
that's filmed by one of the students, that goes viral
and he ends up president, like that's the narrative.
It's like "The West Wing" meets "Veep"
for something like that.
This is the show which was really popular.
Interestingly, his first language is Russian, right?
And I think there's something
about the kind of integration between Ukraine
and Russia that makes this even more complicated
because millions of people in Ukraine have relatives
and friends and et cetera
that live in Russia and vice versa.
Yep.
That makes this tricky.
But then for him to become the president
and for Vitali Klitschko,
the multiple world heavyweight champion boxer
to be mayor of Kyiv, the fact that Louis CK
was meant to be playing a show
in Kyiv like the second night of the invasion.
It turns out he was never in Kyiv I guess.
No, he didn't make it.
But all this makes it very strange.
He's not, he shouldn't be on that list.
He's not one of those guys.
Klitschko is gonna put on a gun at some point
he's gonna go full Rambo, I think at some point.
And the juxtaposition of seeing those images of Putin,
where he's sitting at the end of a super long table,
or at the end of one big kind
of atrium, and his advisors are literally 50 feet away
from him versus Zelenskyy,
who's in a t-shirt and he's literally doing selfie videos,
speaking directly to not just his people,
but to the world in this unedited,
kind of unfiltered way and standing his ground
and saying, this is what we're doing,
I mean, is so fascinating and potent.
He is, and he's saying it he's dropping one liner like,
I don't need a ride, I need weapons
or to be, or not to be, that is the question,
and for us, let me answer it
to parliament in England, it is to be, a great line.
And I'd like to say also he is Jewish
and that matters because the lie
that Putin was telling everybody was
that Ukraine had been taken over by Nazis.
I mean, this is all stuff,
I'm sure a lot of your listeners already know,
but if you don't, if you're not following it,
not everyone's following it as closely.
So that's a lie that they used,
an excuse they used to sell this invasion.
Like we sold the Iraq invasion
with the weapons of mass destruction there.
Nazis have taken over Ukraine.
When in reality Zelenskyy is the offspring
of a sole survivor from a family
that was murdered in the Holocaust from Ukraine.
He's the descendant of a sole survivor
and he's now president and he's wearing this mantle.
And also it matters because,
that's why, when we were joking last week that I was gonna
share this business idea of called Dial-A-Jew.
If you or your friends come across somebody
who is trying to use the Nazi argument
or say something about Nazis in the service of some.
Call a Jew first.
Yeah, first call a Jew first, walk you through it.
We'll walk you through the,
what you're talking points, making sure you got it.
And so the reason that I was gonna make
that joke, although maybe some people think it's
in poor taste, I was gonna make the joke in relation
to some of these vaccine requirement, people that are
using the Nazi comparison or the Holocaust comparison.
But it matters because when you use it even
in a comparison, like the vaccine thing, which is absurd,
it then makes it easy here to use it in another way.
That's absurd and to use it
in this way is the most absurd we've seen yet,
but it didn't start there.
Definitely the most preposterous.
It's the most preposterous, but it didn't start there.
The reason he's able to do that
is because it's been used too many times before,
it's been used in situations, even on the left using it
to paint Trump as a Hitler character when he's not.
So it's like it's used on both sides too often.
And then you create this situation,
where the Jewish president of Ukraine,
the sole survivor is called the lead Nazi.
Right, the idea that we must unseat
this Nazi regime in Ukraine,
and this is a just infiltration of this country
begs the larger conversation around, is it even possible
to have an iron curtain of information in 2022?
Which is what he's trying to achieve.
There was a great episode of "The Daily Today."
Did you listen to the one today?
I did not, no.
So it's all about the disinformation propaganda war.
And it's told through the story of a guy in Ukraine,
who hadn't heard from his dad who lives in Russia.
Like they're like I don't know,
seven, 10 days into the conflict, his dad hasn't called.
He's like, "Why wouldn't my dad call me to see if I'm okay?"
So he calls up his dad and he's like,
dad like just so you know here's what's going on,
we're getting bombed and all this stuff.
And his dad just says, "No, no,
let me tell you what's going on."
And he just parroted the propaganda lie
about unseating the Nazis, right?
Right.
And his dad being an older guy.
Do your own research son.
He has bought into, yeah, he did his own research, right?
Yes.
So he bought into the propaganda lie.
And it's fascinating the extent to which
you can win hearts and minds with state controlled media.
But how does that play out
in a social media infused global community.
So we've seen Russia shut down Facebook, shut down Twitter.
I believe I read the other day
that today, Monday, they're gonna shut down Instagram
as well, which 80 million people,
young people in Russia use for communicating.
I'd read a story that I can't verify.
And I don't have the article in front of me right now,
but that FSB agents were going
to the homes of tech executives from Google and places like
that to either intimidate them or imprison them.
So the war against an open journalistic ecosystem
is very much for real.
But if you're in your twenties
and you're getting your hands on VPNs,
or you know people that live in the West like this,
you can't keep it out on some level.
But you can, for a period of time.
You can, but there's gonna be a demographic split.
Yes.
It's gonna be the older people like this guy's dad,
who's getting its information from RT and VK.
And the young people who rely
on Snapchat and Instagram, and all these other platforms,
where they're getting a more un-moderated,
unfiltered version that the rest of the world is exposed to.
And the fact that we've seen these protests
of people pouring out into the streets
in Moscow and the like knowing that they will be arrested
for that and doing it anyway,
shows the extent to which
this is unpopular war even within Russia.
Yes.
And then the question becomes, does that matter to Putin?
Or at what point does Russian unrest with this decision
that Putin has made become a substantive factor
in how he's making decisions?
Or does he not care?
At some point that balance tips
and he has to take that into consideration.
It could take years though,
for like the drum beat on the streets, right?
It's gonna take a mass casualties.
Like it took a decade in Afghanistan, I think for them.
And it took them taking on mass casualties.
It could take that.
To your point about Instagram,
I was messaging with Alexey Molchanov,
the great free diver champion world champion.
And we were talking and he was basically
sad about everything and I just checking
in on him and of course expected that I feel bad
for these great Russian friends of mine
and athletes, and that want no part of anything political
and Alexey is a businessman, he wants his business going.
And I said,
"Do you have an international home for your business?"
He does so he's probably taken care of.
Is it on his $600 million yacht
parked in the Maldives right now?
He's not one of those guys.
Do you know that guy
on Twitter, who tracks all the super yachts
and where they are at all times?
Yes.
Super interesting.
There's the one I think they found in the-
They found Putin's.
They found Putin's, right yeah.
Yeah and it's interesting to pay attention
to the oligarchs and whether like their perspective
on this becomes meaningful for Putin.
I mean, he basically created all
of these people and empowered them.
Well, so word about that,
so I've looked into some of this.
So the oligarchs, the ones that we talk
about when we say the oligarchs like Roman Abramovich,
I think is the guy that owns the Chelsea Football Club.
Not anymore.
Is it Chelsea or Manchester?
Chelsea.
So basically what happened was
Yeltsin sold off the goods, right?
Yeltsin sold off the goods
to people he was connected to, those people bought,
and by the goods means natural resources,
they bid on natural resources bid
on real estate, whatever it is that the state owned,
they paid peanuts for it, they got it.
They ended up becoming wealth like oligarchs overnight.
Putin, when he came in, he didn't oversee that,
but he basically made it legal.
He basically came in and propped and tidied up
that whole thing and said, okay, you guys have it now.
And I'm gonna make,
'cause Yeltsin was a bit of a mess, right?
And so I'm gonna make this look tidier.
And so he enabled them
in certain ways, but he didn't sell them the goods.
I think that's important just in point of information.
Right, but that engendered a loyalty.
For sure.
So they know that their large S is a result
of Putin, so there's an allegiance there,
but how tenuous is that allegiance
and how important is the tenuous nature
of that allegiance, should that come to pass?
Scott Galloway on the "Pivot Podcast"
that he does with Kara Swisher,
Scott being a professor of business
at NYU, and like he's a very interesting thinker
basically just said, if he doesn't think
that the oligarchs will be problematic
because of that loyalism but
at some point, if it becomes a challenge for Putin,
he can just take it all back and nationalize everything.
And then dole it back out to the loyalists at some point.
So he always holds that Trump card.
That's probably what more than loyalty.
That's probably what keeps them from speaking out
to vociferously and thinking about the World War III thing,
it's funny that, we all know
the reason World War II was one by the Allies.
Isn't just because the US stepped in,
it's also because Russia helped defeat the Nazis, right?
They burned down their own towns
to starve out the German army.
And when this was all happening,
I always thought in the back
of my mind, if this really did get
to a place where World War III possible,
I bet China becomes the unlikely ally
'cause Russia was not an ally of the United States
going into World War II.
Nobody, no United States government was really stoked
with the new socialist empire that was growing in,
so close to Europe.
So would China play a role of
'cause China wants things stable?
Sure, but there allegiance right now
to Russia is deeply concerning and I think the question is,
and the uncertainty revolves around
how substantive that allegiance is.
I don't think it's.
And I think the fact
that Russia is, you can make the argument
that Russia is losing this war right now.
Right.
And that's gotta make China think like,
are we backing the right horse?
Or maybe we kind of slowly step back on that.
I think that's what's gonna happen.
And I think that, but I do think China is in a good position
to actually help end it.
If there is an off ramp
for Russia, for Putin it's via China, I think so.
The off ramp conversation is interesting.
Because there's certainly the argument
that in order to resolve this
as quickly and as safely as possible,
we have to provide Putin
with a way to save face and to get out
of this without looking like he was the colossal failure
that he is in this instance, right?
Right.
So how do you do that?
I don't think you can.
You can't and I listened to another podcast
between Sam Harrison and Gary Kasparov,
the world chess champion.
Who's become this advocate for democracy and is on Twitter,
basically tweeting all day about this situation.
Where's he lives?
He's been talk, I don't know
where he lives, but I mean, he's been decrying
the heels of Putin forever, right?
Right.
And so he has a very interesting lens on this
as somebody who was successful in Russia, saw the rise
of Putin and has been decrying, sort of calling out
like, "Hey, this is where we're headed."
Like in a sort of Cassandra way for a very long time.
And his whole thing is
that like sanctions are too little too late.
Like sanctions could have been more effective
prior to the invasion.
But now that the invasion is underway,
if there's tanks rolling
and planes flying, like sanctions doesn't arrest that.
And he's calling for, he's one of the few people
who's calling for a no-fly zone.
And he was kind of articulating that argument.
Now, I don't know that, I think that's the right idea here,
but he's basically saying like,
this is like a cancer and you gotta like take it out.
You gotta like put the scalpel in there
and cut the whole thing out in order to address it.
Two things, sanction, sanctions.
There's an argument that sanctions never work.
They never did work, they never will work.
They make the masses suffer,
the people in power don't suffer, they're not suffering,
they might suffer on the balance sheet,
but they're not suffering.
But once the masses suffer enough
that becomes untenable for the government.
The argument is to make the masses suffer
to the point where they rebel, right?
And that's, it is a brutal game to play the sanctions game.
You make the masses suffer but what ends up happening
is instead of the people rising up too often,
it increases domestic authoritarianism.
And Iran is the greatest example of that.
Iran, sanctions has not worked toppling this Iranian regime
that is not democratic in any way.
And there's plenty of people
that would like that to not be a theocratic dictatorship
that live in Iran, The Green Party.
Just like there's plenty
of people in Russia, the opposition party
that majority wants Putin out, doesn't work.
So I'm not saying it to not do it because it is kind of,
it has been instructive to see
how quickly like the global community has siphoned up
and crunched rush economically, I never saw that coming.
I didn't think it would have that impact.
I don't think we've ever seen an economic sanctions,
I guess, cascade sanctions quite like this in our lives.
Well, yeah, because the world
is so much more interconnected now.
So when payment systems go offline in Russia.
And Samsung is no longer sending,
it's like everything that they manufacture
in Russia is built on parts that come externally.
And when you shut down the import export
with Russia, they can't do anything.
So I think the fact will be more dramatic in the short term
than it has perhaps historically
in other sanctions scenarios in the past.
Yes and then as to whether we should impose a no-fly zone,
basically that would be
the beginning of World War III, right?
That would be, because if you shoot down a Russian plane
and you're Ukrainian, that's one thing,
if you shoot down a Russian plane
and you're United States Navy or Air Force pilot,
that's a whole different thing.
It's weird how diplomacy works that way.
Because these are subtle differences like
if we get aircraft from Poland and then provide it
to the Ukrainians, ostensibly, the result is similar.
But if we have a no-fly zone,
then we're just one step closer
to being a direct participant
in this, but it's somewhat semantics.
But we already are right?
We are already are to some degree.
And that goes to the point you were making earlier
about the fragile, delicate nature of all of this.
Right, because this is a crazy person.
Would he push a button,
even though it would annihilation on his part?
Would he, like would he?
I mean would he?
So you wonder and, but you have to wonder,
and you have to be very careful there.
So I don't say it's Chamberlain and I understand
why Ukrainians want the no-fly zone, I get it.
We should, I think, at least give them
what they need to impose their own, at the very least.
It's interesting, there's some stories coming outta here
that show you the beauty of humanity.
We talked about Zelenskyy,
we talked about the grit of people like Klitschko,
but just in generally the Ukrainian people.
And like farmers getting tanks and driving them away,
like all these crazy stories
that we're seeing play out on social media.
Roman Matsyuta, the Ukrainian actor,
who's like literally just filmed a movie
about being an actor and then Russia invading
and then having to join the army and this is him.
He act actually happened, he just film the movie,
the movie's out on Amazon Prime, I guess.
Again, this meta weird nature of this whole thing.
I actually reached out to his PR guy, his PR woman.
You did?
I did, I tried to get him.
I tried to get some quotes from him, couldn't be reached,
'cause he is in the army now is what she said.
But she has a heavy metal band,
she wants to hook me up with, a Ukrainian heavy metal band.
So here's a, if you're watching
on YouTube, we pulled up a post of him, so is that him?
That's Holly McKay's, we talked
about her before, when she was reporting in Afghanistan.
She's in Ukraine now, that's where I got it, yeah.
But in the garb that Roman's wearing here
is that his costume from the movie?
Or is that him armed and ready to--
No, I think my understanding
I haven't communicated with her about this post.
But my understanding is she took
that picture, when she was reporting in Kyiv.
And here's his actual Instagram account.
He only has 715 followers.
Bro don't social media shame, it's awful.
No, what I'm saying
is that like what this story is unbelievable.
I understand, but look
at his look, like wouldn't you wanna read one of those?
Look at it, he's on vacation.
How many weeks ago was he on vacation?
It's so weird, how things can change so quickly,
oh right here?
Yeah.
Yeah, here he is at the beach.
December?
I dunno, man.
Yeah December, 2021, so I love that story,
I hope he's okay, like really love to all the Ukrainians
enduring this debacle and this tragedy, refugee situation.
There's like TikToks of like teenage girls
in the subway, you know how they're all
like down in there for bomb shelter reasons.
And they're like, "Here's what it's like in the like TikTok,
like here's a day in the life,
in Ukraine right now, in Kyiv in the subway tunnels."
There babies being delivered in subway tunnels.
There are, what's it called,
when you pay someone to carry your baby for you?
I forget.
Midwife?
No, a surrogate.
Yes.
There's apparently a surrogate business
and there's 18 newborns
that can't be picked up by their parents.
Oh my God.
In like a basement in Kyiv.
There was a great "Dailyish" episode
on refugees, a couple of New York Times reporters
embedded with refugees leaving the country
on their way towards Poland, I believe it was.
And that's really good, I recommend that.
I listen to that, it was heartbreaking.
Yeah, it's unbelievable.
Like that's that kids carrying there pets.
What's that reporter's name?
The woman reporter.
We've read her stuff before.
She's great, she has command of the language
and she's talking to everybody in there,
this caravan of people, who's trying to get
to Poland and all the people that she meets along the way
spending the night in that kindergarten.
Yeah, it's Sabrina Tavernise, yeah, she's fabulous.
She's doing some amazing reporting right now.
Fabulous and even on the other side of it,
the stories of all these Ukrainians showing up
two and a half million, I think have left Ukraine now,
people showing up in the train station
in Berlin and thousands of Berliners turning up
with would you like to organized chaos
their trying to find people and feed them and house them.
I just read two young kids developed an app
to try to help pair refugees with places to stay.
So it's those little beautiful silver linings
in all of this that give you hope for humanity.
No doubt.
Meanwhile, do we wanna talk about Brittney Griner?
Brittney Griner, WNBA player.
She was a great college player
a WNBA champion, seven-time All Star.
Was travel to Russia for the Russian basketball season.
The women basketball players, as many of you may know,
go to Russia to compete because they get paid
five times as much, maybe more
in Russia than they do in the United States.
So they go there in the Off season,
which is really their primary season.
And she went and she got arrested
at the airport, picked up and was charged with a crime
of having, I think like hashish oil cartridges,
just like vape pen cartridges.
Vape pen and stuff.
But now there's a lot
of people think that you can't really take
that seriously, that charge because it hasn't been proven.
And plenty of people are picked up
for political reasons in Russia.
There's more, she's one of 50 I think
that's imprisoned right now
and you can't necessarily believe the charges.
And so she's just like in the system over there.
And there's no update.
No update.
Since she's been incarcerated.
I mean, you just have to imagine.
She's won gold medals for the US.
It's crazy, I feel like
we should be talking about this a little bit more.
I mean, obviously it's one story
in the midst of a tragic situation,
where lots of lives are being sacrificed,
but I can't help but think that
if it was Tom Brady or somebody like that,
the whole world would be erupting over this.
In this story, this is a CNN story
by Don Riddle and he interviews, let me see,
the Iranian journalist, Jason Rezaian.
Who was the guy that was in Tehran and was picked up,
he'd been there several times before.
And he was picked up on his last trip
and your held for 544 days.
And so Jason doesn't believe these charges at all.
Doesn't believe they should be repeated,
so I probably already committed a faux pas
but just to be very clear
on the veracity of what's being the accusation here.
Meanwhile, the first American journalist
was killed in Ukraine, this guy, Brent Renaud.
Yep.
So not to be overly American-centric
about this whole thing but-
Filmmaker, I think he was working
for Time doing a documentary on migration I think it was,
if I remember correctly.
Time Studios on the global refugee crisis.
Yeah, and I think the word did we say about the refugees
as we get into Brent's work,
his work has been lauded, his won awards,
and people were raving about him
and it is very sad and it is part of the business.
It happens almost every conflict,
great journalists are hurt.
They put themselves in harm's way,
they're called to do it and they do it.
And I've been into a couple of different situations,
where it could have gone bad for me.
I've always adopted the idea,
it's only a good idea if you can get home,
it's only a good idea if you get home safely, you know?
But there is, it takes a certain type
of individual and a certain type
of disposition to be attracted to this kind of work.
And this is something that has come up on the podcast
when I had Dan Harrison, like being a war correspondent,
like there's a rush to that.
There's a dopamine charge.
I'm somebody who would be very attracted
to that because it's so exciting.
And you're right in the middle
of what the world is talking about.
And that has to be intoxicating.
And the danger is an aspect of that heightened allure.
100%, 100%.
But this is the flip side
of that, because that danger is real.
It's real, and you have no control over it.
And you put yourself into this situation
and sometimes you want that rush so badly,
you make poor choices, I'm not saying that happened here.
He was killed, I think at a checkpoint
and he didn't do anything wrong
or it wasn't his fault.
But it is being in the wrong place at the wrong time.
But other than just deciding to do the job,
which is the job that he wanted and that he loved doing.
And the thing about it though,
that I would say is that like,
the thing I've learned about my job
is that we always, we do get wrapped up
in these stories and we get wrapped up
in telling them and we think they're really important
and they are, but they also aren't.
And that's what I've learned over the years is like that,
there's not one story I've done that you can point to
that's about a humanitarian crisis
that has made any difference in that crisis and I'm not.
That's a pretty pessimistic prospective.
It's not necessarily being pessimistic.
I'm just saying, it doesn't nothing I've personally done,
I'm not criticizing Brent's work or anybody's work.
It's just something I've noticed is like,
as a journalist looking
at this stuff and does the coverage help or not?
And it does, if you can have breaking news
that really shows corruption,
or you can, there's Pulitzer Prize winning reporting
on humanitarian crises that do change the world.
But most of it's just more noise about war, most of it.
Yeah and I think it's also important
to understand that this conflict in Ukraine is not unique.
I mean, there's similar situations going on
in Africa and South America, that don't get the level
of attention that this is getting
and obviously this is an extreme, horrible situation,
but it's important to not just see it in isolation.
Well right, the refugee crisis is a good example, right?
We had, there were an Indian family
of four just froze to death in Canada
that was trying to get into the United States,
but got screwed by their smuggler.
There's people moving all over the place,
the Syrians that are still in camps,
not everybody gets a welcome in Berlin.
That's not to criticize anybody involved in any of that.
I understand why Ukraine has captured
the attention of the world.
It's not just because of a connection
to European roots, although that's part of it.
But it's also that this is an inspiring kind of group.
The Ukrainians have inspired the world
in a way that's unique.
And so I think that it's hard to decouple those two things.
But they both are part of it, I think.
Quick final thought before we it's turn our attention
to the floods in Australia.
Ryan Holladay made this post the other day
that I thought was fantastic.
He is donating all book sales earnings
that he's received over the years
from as many books that have come from Russia and Ukraine
and donating those proceeds to Ukrainian causes.
And this is kind of caused
other authors to jump in and do the same,
Tim Ferris, Robert Green, Neil Straus have followed suit.
I don't know that I've ever, I don't think
that I have any book sale earnings from Russia and Ukraine,
because I don't have books that have been published there.
But I wanted to just alert people to that fact
and to the extent that there are...
I'm gonna email and find out though,
'cause if I do and figure out a way to contribute.
Even if I don't like some other way,
but I thought that was really cool
and they've all been posting about it.
And I think it's said in motion this thing
where all these other authors are doing the same,
people have sold those books.
That's cool.
So that's another kind of cool hopeful thing.
Of course now the middle class Russians
can't buy a single book anymore so.
No, they're not saying, right.
(Adam laughing)
The library's open, only for state approved literature.
You can burn my books for fire.
Right.
Yes.
Let's talk about the floods in Australia.
Second spell of 100 year floods
in two years in Queensland.
I think the worst of it was the devastation
was on the border lands
between Queensland, Northeast, South Wales, correct?
Yeah.
Thousands homeless, injured and dead.
So little coverage of this in the US.
Incredible.
Unbelievable.
Like I don't understand it
well because the last spade of floods were covered well.
I mean these floods, I mean, they're like,
you'd see these storefronts that are completely underwater.
I mean 10 feet high, 12 feet high.
Higher, I think that there was a McDonalds pole,
where it was like.
You got only the top was peeking out above it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Unbelievable that-
Even Sydney was flooded, Manly was flooded.
The rains are still going, it is I think,
people were saved, people broke out boats, ala Katrina.
Mick Fanning was going around on a jet.
Mick Fanning and Joel Parkinson, the Russian,
they live up there at Tweed's heads.
I think Mick Fanning lives up there
and he, yeah, they rescued pets and a pharmacist.
There was a story in The Guardian where Mick Fanning,
a pharmacist wanted to open her pharmacy
and she lived in Tweed Heads
and she needed a ride in a boat.
And Mick Fanning turned up on a jet ski
and said, "Come on, let's go do it."
And then along the way, they had to tow some other boat
and they barely made it under an overpass and incredible.
I mean, I feel personally connected
to this on some level, just because I've spent time
in Byron and my friends and podcast guests,
Simon Hill and Ross Edgley are both in Byron Bay right now.
And Ross has sent me some videos
from what it actually, 'cause I keep for,
because it gets so little coverage.
Like it's we're not being inundated with news about it,
we're underestimating just how devastating it is there.
And like what a rough go Australia has had with the fires
that were occurring when I was visiting there
before the pandemic, to these floods,
I mean it's just devastating.
Two, 100-year floods in two years.
Right.
That's crazy.
And we have to talk about
the impact of man-made climate change on all of this
and the role like this tool, Scott Morrison.
Yes ScoMo.
The PM is playing in all
of this as this flack for the coal industry.
He is, they call him Scott
from marketing over there because he is like really adept
at setting up these really transparent photo shoots.
Here I am cleaning up graffiti,
here's me with a shovel on that, I've never used before.
Here's me with a koala bear.
But meanwhile, everything he does
behind closed doors is to undermine
all the things that are contributing to all of this,
like his advancement of coal
and fossil fuels and all of that.
And essentially being like a bit of a climate denier, right?
Well, he was trying to also open up
the Great Australian Bight to oil drilling.
Did we talk about that?
I think maybe we did.
I think I did a story,
I did a piece on that for WSL PURE ages ago.
And that's how I got connected
to Sean Doherty, the longtime surf journalist
turned climate environmental preservation champion,
and he was heavy involved
in saving the Great Australian Bight.
There were a bunch of paddle outs to save the Bight.
The Bight is similar to the Gulf of California
in that it's this confluence of currents
that create an incredible ecosystem,
several species of whale, sea lion colonies, a tuna fishery,
a lot going on there and
an incredible fragile and important ecosystem.
And they wanted to basically drill for oil,
explore for oil in the middle of all this at this time.
I mean like knowing what we know now.
It doesn't make any sense
and so he has this great parody account.
Basically, he just gives-
Seano888.
Yeah, he just gives ScoMo the business.
I mean, it's is the constant tirade
of Anti ScoMo would you play this one video
that he posted because this is classic.
Like, you know this one, this TikTok?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me start it over.
This is coal, don't be afraid,
don't be scared, it's coal,
it was dug up for over 100 years.
The deputy prime minister.
Australia has enjoyed energy competitive advantage.
For those that are listening,
there's just images of floods everywhere.
As that has been able remain competitive
on a new global market, Mr. speaker those officers have
an ideological, pathological fear of coal.
There's no room for coal phobia officially Mr. Speaker,
but that's the melody that afflicts those officers.
But it's that melody Mr. speaker that is affecting the jobs
in towns and the industries and indeed in this country,
because of their pathological, ideological opposition
to coal being an important part
of our sustainable and more certain energy, a future.
So on this side of the house, Mr. Speaker,
you will not find a fear of coal, this is coal.
And he went, I think it was during the fires.
He loves coal.
Two years ago during the middle of the bushfire crisis,
he went on a family vacation to Hawaii.
Right, I remember that
'cause I was in Australia when that was going on.
He's basically Ted Cruz.
He's Ted Cruz without the personality.
(both chuckling)
Did you see this article about the snakes and the spiders?
I did. (laughs)
A lot some of these articles
are behind pay walls and stuff like that.
But basically, as the floodwaters start to recede,
Australia is known for its predatory reptiles.
Yes.
And of course-
They're going everywhere.
They're coming out.
They're here to party.
Exactly, so what did it say, like.
I think you had pythons, venomist red-bellied snakes
and eastern browns, the second most lethal on the planet
after the inland taipan, also in Australian species,
are on the move after floods across the populous East,
forced them from their lowland hideouts.
Yeah, it's awful, there was also this
it's another article that's behind a paywall,
but on Instagram you can kind of see the Saturday Paper,
front page image of this guy.
And he's talking about a baby and his parents buried
almost neck deep in mud.
But they got, the baby survived, right?
It's crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
Mick Fanning also posted some good places to contribute
and get involved for those that are interested.
The main one being Givit, G-I-V-I-T.
Okay.
Which he shared about on his Instagram.
I reposted this the other day.
And I think people were giving in Ukraine,
weren't they giving Airbnbs people were like hiring Airbnbs,
like random Airbnbs in Kyiv and just booking it
for like a year out or something like that.
And then just, and then donating it.
Or giving the money, like making sure
you can pay right away, so they had money.
That's another thing people are doing for families.
Wow, it's cool.
All right, well why don't we
turn to some listener questions?
Well, I just wanna say another word
about fellow journalists out there.
I mean, it's not just the rush
from being in it, although that's part of it.
Well, first of all, who's the guy, the travel vlogger guy?
Oh right.
Yeah, we forgot to talk about him, what's his name again?
I started following him.
Yeah, I'll find it right now.
He is not technically a journalist, right?
Well, he wasn't, before all this,
he was more of a travel writer I think.
He happened to be there when this all happened
and just sort of stepped up
to being somebody who's gonna cover it new on the ground.
Let me find it.
Terrell J Star.
Cultural ambassador and travel expert for Ukraine.
That's what he was in Pakistan and Georgia.
I think he's been over there for years.
Yoga lover, runner and he follows, he followed Rich.
So shout out to Terrell, if you're listening to this.
Yeah, great work, Terrell.
And this is like here he is.
So there's a part of like
what drives us, like I think it's not just to be the one
that gets the story, it's not just to be in the mix.
And it's when you're a journalist, you see the world,
it's like the ultimate way to see the world.
You see it at close range,
in an intimate way, being accepted and getting the stories
from the real local people.
And you see it in a way that's different
than any other way you can travel.
And there's an empathy there that we share
that we do care about the people generally
that we reporting on, we do care
about the cultures that we're injecting ourselves into.
How could you not? 'cause it's not well paid.
It's not particularly thought of,
especially now in a positive way by the people,
by the majority of the public, it's hazardous.
And so I just wanted to say that
because I respect all these war correspondent doing.
I devour the work, I love it.
It's, I think what I was trying to get across was
that we should also, when we're putting ourselves into those
I was speaking more for my fellow journalist
when we put ourselves into situations
to make sure we know why we're doing it.
And to make sure that we're not trying
to make ourselves bigger than, it's not like we go
into it thinking it's going to be this big thing
and it's going to save people,
like don't do it with some sort of Messiah complex.
I don't think he did, I'm just saying in my own mind,
sometimes that comes up
because you're thinking I'm doing this for you,
source or country, but really we do it for ourselves,
but we also do it because it's a great way to see the world
and a great way to share time with people, really is.
And an opportunity for us to express ourselves
and to scream and yell and rage and holler and sing,
all of that, so I respect everyone out there doing it.
And I think this is a great story.
Here's a guy that was more of a travel expert,
a social media travel guy
who is now like really bringing out
some of the more interesting stories
that are coming out of Ukraine.
And he's doing it through Instagram as far as I know.
And so big ups to Terrell J Star.
It is an interesting adventuresome life though.
Yeah, it is.
You know?
Yeah, it's great.
And to be able to be boots-on-the-ground,
tell stories from a firsthand experience
and kind of pursue your curiosity.
Absolutely.
It's a pretty interesting way to live.
I've had a gun pointed at me
in a rough part of Honduras for a story,
I've almost been attacked by a mob in Lombok, in Indonesia.
I've had those moments that have happened,
I've been and I actually remember them fondly,
but they're not necessarily easy moments or they're scary.
And your pulse rate goes down and you just like,
it's very moment-to-moment.
It's unlike anything else I've ever or felt really.
So if you were dispatched to Ukraine right now,
what would the story be that you would be pursuing?
Like what would provoke your curiosity?
What's the story that you're not hearing about?
Rich, I'm no longer a global traveler that-
You're pushing a stroller and saying, "What's up daddy?"
I'm saying, "Let's rock and roll gang."
That's what I do.
You know what, of all the stories that I've seen come out,
I think the refugee story probably is the most interesting
that Sabrina did and like hanging out in that aspect of it.
I think were I single and not a father right now,
would I be, since I actually do have the cash
to go over there, there's been whole periods of time,
where I couldn't have funded myself, would I do it?
It's an interesting question.
Plenty of like doctors are going to Poland
and trying to help refugees on that side of border.
I've tended to be the under-reported story guy.
And so when the whole world goes to Ukraine,
I probably wouldn't do that because I'm not working.
I don't have a connection
to Daily News editors on that level,
so I typically try to find the under-reported story.
But I will say this, like seeing what's happening
in Ukraine and Russia, we are focused on that.
For many years I covered Burma and Myanmar
and they've had a military dictatorship.
They just retook the country, this military did,
they've crunched down social media,
you can't get on social media.
They've kept their foot on the neck
of the people for generations.
And we've done business with them.
EU done business with them,
Japan's done business with them this whole time.
So it is interesting when you've covered other places
that have had similar situations
and the Burmese fought back, there's been fighting.
I mean, not just the Burmese,
but the different ethnic armies in the provinces
have fought back against this domination
for generations as well.
And nobody's given them a bunch of weapons.
So when you see that, you do wonder, but at the same time,
like you understand, because Ukraine has actually managed
to cut through all the divisive, polarized bullshit.
And the United States, aside
from people that work at Fox News
typically agree that Putin is a bad person.
And that we should be rooting at least for Ukraine.
That's an accomplishment, yeah.
Yeah.
Well, more will be revealed.
More will be revealed.
And we'll do our best to bring you our perspective
if that's what you wanna hear, who knows?
Yeah.
Do people wanna hear us talk about Ukraine?
I don't know.
I think we just did Ukraine.
We just did.
Do you wanna do Ukraine again
and see if we can do it better?
(both laughing)
I'm sure we could.
Yes.
All right let's get to the listener question.
We have three listener questions,
and they all pivot around one theme for the most part.
They're all sobriety, it's a sobriety theme.
It is.
Before we get into it, let me ask you a quick question.
What do you think of the psychedelic day spas
that are proliferating?
I didn't know that there were such a thing.
Let's do that story next.
All right, we can do that next.
I have lots of thoughts on this.
Yeah, that's important I think.
I can't answer that in one or two sentences.
No, plus that way I can share about my early experience
in the legalized medical marijuana reporting
that I was doing years ago.
I look forward to hearing that, spa, where are these spas?
Wouldn't you like to know?
Maybe, I shouldn't know.
Julie, from Kansas City.
Hi, Rich and Adam, this is Julie from Kansas City.
Just wanted to say, "Tusen takk,"
which is Norwegian for, a thousand thanks
because that really just expressed the amount
of gratitude I have for the podcast.
I wanted to take a brief second,
just to tell my husband, Drew, of how proud I am
of him these past handful of years.
And it's been the greatest joy
of my life to watch his road to recovery.
My question is, as our kids are getting older
and are starting to enter the tween years,
what are some pointers or advice that you could give us
for talking about alcoholism, addiction, sobriety,
and recovery with our children?
Appreciate you both and hope you have a great day.
Thank you, Julie.
It's a great question, it's a really important question.
Perhaps one of, if not the most important thing
to be thinking about as a parent,
as your kids enter these tween and ultimately teenage years.
I've been through this myself
and I have lots of opinions about this and thoughts on it.
I think it's really important to be honest with your kids
and not communicate to them in the way
perhaps our parents did,
where like it's just drugs are bad.
I don't think that really works
this idea of making them scared or labeling
with judgment, what drugs are and what drugs aren't.
I think it's much more effective,
especially since it sounds like,
so Drew, her husband is in recovery.
It sounds like it, yeah.
To be transparent about that,
to talk openly with your kids about your own history
and Drew's history with drugs and alcohol, I think is key.
And in that, what I mean by that is
you can just talk to them like on some level,
not that they're adults,
but you can say, look, I understand that
you're gonna be faced with temptations.
Other kids are gonna be doing this.
There is an allure to it.
You'll be in a situation where you feel like
if you wanna fit in, you're gonna have to do it.
And you could talk about like, when I was doing it,
here's what happened to me and it was great.
And I had fun and this is,
you could talk about the positives and the negatives.
I think the more open and honest you are,
the more trust you engender with your kids.
So you tell good stories too.
I mean, Julie has told crazy stories to our kids
about like stuff that she did when she was really young,
like growing up in Alaska.
Where she got accidentally dosed with acid
and what happened to her and you can kind of talk about it,
you can do it with levity is what I'm saying.
And I think my perspective has always been,
look here's how it started for me.
And here's what it did for me.
And here's how I think in many ways
it like kind of soothed me or was
a bandaid to this emotional wound that I had,
but ultimately I couldn't control it.
And here's what happened as a result.
And I've taken my kids to AA meetings
and they know my whole history
and all my AA friends, I have lots of a friends.
They come over to the house, they share.
Like we're all very open about it.
And I think it creates an environment of permissibility
to talk about it, as opposed to it being this voodoo subject
that everyone tiptoes around and is scared to talk about
or does it in a very kind of binary reductive way.
Right, do you think that's
because it's a foreground conclusion, kids will experiment.
It's the rare kid that doesn't try something.
Yeah, they're gonna be exposed to it.
And if you think otherwise you're delusional, right?
So this is going on all around you.
And if you think, my kid's a good kid,
he would never do that.
Or this is not happening with my kid.
Like you're not living in reality.
Like this is going on all over the place all the time.
And to the extent that you have a really good grip
on like what your kid is doing at school all day long,
like I've learned, and I've seen
in other people, like they have their own lives outside
of the at, and they choose
what to share with you and what not to share with you.
Which gets to my point about like, keeping that channel
of communication as open and as honest as possible.
In my experience, that's absolutely key.
And if you just villainize drugs
or you talk down to your kids,
or you speak about this subject matter
in a very judgmental tone, then they're not gonna feel safe
or comfortable coming to you to ask you questions
about it, or to confess to something that has happened,
or to ask for advice about what they should do,
because this kid did that and they were
in this situation and they didn't know how to behave.
Plus if he's only been in recovery for a few years
and they're gonna be tweens, they've already seen stuff.
Certainly, right?
And it's sort of like,
okay, at tweens, like, so how old exactly?
Like you do have to, like,
they need to be mature enough to be able to-
Understand.
So I'm talking more about 15, around 14, 15.
You wouldn't start at 11
or 12, when talking about this staff?
Well, no, I think it's a different conversation
at 11 and 12, you can share your experience.
And I would encourage taking the kids to these AA meetings.
Like that's they get exposed to,
they get to absorb kind of the environment.
And I think when they're
at open meetings and they see people get up
and share with a level
of vulnerability and honesty about their past
and their mishaps, and their foibles and how they got
into trouble and how they built their lives back up,
like that's impactful on a young mind.
And they can see that rollercoaster ride,
that drugs and alcohol takes people on.
And I think also,
you need to have a healthy appreciation
for the lack of control, you're gonna be able
to exert on these kids as they get older.
Like you have to surrender and accept that,
you're not gonna be able to dictate their decisions
when they're at school, like you can't be with them 24/7.
And these opportunities
to drink or use are going to present at themselves.
Your kid is gonna make a choice.
Quite often, kids make the wrong choice
and your job is to provide this safe place
for them to process this.
I think the kid has to feel like it's their idea.
Like I wanna talk to my parent
about this, or I'm gonna choose not
to use, but it's almost like forming an inception.
Like you have to create an environment where
it's conducive to them developing
like the level of self-efficacy
and agency in their life, where they're going
to make that better decision to have the gumption
and the sense of self
to be able to say no under social pressure, right?
Yeah.
It's tough though, man.
Self-sufficiency, self-efficacy, self-esteem,
the more kids feel good about themselves
and feel like they have a direction in their life,
they're secure in their social environment.
They have a belief in their competence
and hope for their future, the less likely they're gonna be
to sacrifice those values or desires
for that social approval in those tricky situations.
But it's tough, man, this is a tough road ahead,
all kids go through this deep desire to fit in.
And this is something that every parent
is gonna have to confront and navigate with their kids.
And I think, but I think the parents
that have the hardest time with it are the ones
who think they're not gonna have to deal with this.
Because they've parented in a certain way
where they're certain
that their kid is gonna be able to transcend this.
And those are the ones who have the biggest come ups
and it comes as such a surprise
to them because they feel like they did everything
to prevent it from happening and it happens.
Even when you do that, this stuff comes off.
Well, I think it's very clear in life
that the more certain you are about a certain outcome,
the more fucked up you're gonna be pretty soon after.
I know.
Well, as somebody who's been a parent
for a minute and has weathered teen years
and you has young adults now and all that kind of stuff,
I always sort of chuckle when I meet young parents
or parents that are kind of in the situation
that you're in and they're like, here's what we're doing.
And they have this whole plan, like here's the school.
And then we're gonna expose the kid
to this and he's gonna love this.
And this is what we're gonna plug him into.
And this is how it's gonna play out.
And I'm just like,
"All right, well, we'll see how that goes."
(both laughing)
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
The more you try to exert
that control and it comes from a place of love.
Every parent wants to see their kid flourish
and they wanna put them
in those environments and you should be doing all of that,
but you have to hold these things lightly.
And kind of detach from your expectations
and the more you hold onto it,
the more of a lesson you're in for, I think.
I think you're right.
And it's your point about self-esteem being so key,
doesn't it help a kid's self-esteem when their parents
are being kind of honest and raw with them?
'cause it makes them feel like a grownup, right?
Yeah, I made these mistakes.
Like I think when parents try to say,
I'm the ultimate authority.
And this is right, and this is wrong
and you have to do this.
Kids are very astute because they see the dissonance
between what comes out of a parent's mouth
and how they actually behave.
And that means that you need to align your behavior
with your words, but you also have
to be honest and transparent about your mistakes
and things that you had to learn the hard way.
And I think that creates a relatability
and a level of trust that is super important here.
And look, when that situation arises and you find out
that your kid got drunk at a party or whatever it is,
you want them to feel like they can
come and tell you about that and be honest about it.
And you're not gonna have to catch them in a lie
or discover it some other way
because they wouldn't tell you about it.
That's because the communication is shut down
and they don't trust you or they don't feel comfortable
talking to you about this
because they're afraid they're gonna be judged.
They could still be sentenced to child labor for a day,
if you want, I mean, after they got drunk at the party.
There can be ramifications for this, of course.
Is child labor okay?
I mean, I'm new to this, so I just wanna know.
Yeah, I don't know child labor in what form?
Like mow the lawn or we're putting you on a plane to-
Bangladeshi sweat shop.
Yeah, I would also highly suggest, Julie,
that you check out if you haven't,
if you missed it the first time around
the podcast that I did with Jessica Lahey on her book,
"The Addiction Inoculation" that's episode 593,
'cause we talk about all of this stuff.
And if you haven't read that book yet,
I would definitely pick that up, she's the boss.
That was a great question.
I have to props to Julie from KC.
I love Kansas City by the way.
Cool.
Big fan.
Back to Kansas, where the scene of "The Day After".
I think it was Lawrence, Kansas.
I think it was Lawrence,
which is not far from Kansas city.
Believe me if it happened again.
I just remember there was a swing set.
I can like there's a empty swing set
and then the mushroom cloud.
I remember that.
Do you remember that?
Yeah, it was very haunting.
I have another, well it's too late.
We've already talked about that's we're moving on.
We're getting into some really
uplifting stuff like sobriety.
All right, Nathan from Boston.
Hi, Rich and Adam.
This is Nathan from Boston area.
So I have four months
before I'm going to be admitted to a 30-day program.
That's a joint program
for alcoholism, and anxiety and depression.
So my question is this, what advice would you give somebody
that knows they need recovery?
My friend and my wife have posed this to me
and I'm accepting it, but I have four months before I go in.
And during that four months,
I'm starting to wax and wane between completely sobering up
and going in as a sober person or giving up
and just, I almost said enjoying the next four months,
but you know what I mean.
Spiritually, pragmatically, cognitively,
like I'm struggling on so many levels
of how to deal with the next four months.
And I wanna make the best
of the situation, but it's getting difficult.
And so any advice you have is greatly appreciated.
Thank you, bye.
Nathan, I would say that you are suffering
from the alcoholic's paradox, right?
Like it's the two wolves, right?
Like which wolf do you feed?
So on the one hand, listen you know you need to get sober.
You've been intervened on, your friends are telling you,
you've got to go, you've relented to this intervention
and agreed to go to this treatment center for 30 days.
It's not come coming up for four months.
So the good devil's like, well, you should get sober now.
And then when you go get into treatment,
you can really, hit the accelerator
and create this amazing foundation of sobriety.
But the alcoholic is like, I got four months.
Yeah, four good months.
It's party time.
Like it's time to really accelerate this thing, right?
And I get that, I understand that like,
look, I'm going to treatment in four months.
I might as well go out with a bang.
Well don't a lot of people get high
the night before they check in?
Dude, I did, I showed up
on the doorstep of my treatment center completely loaded.
Like I tried to make the most out of that last day.
I'm not recommending that.
No.
I think that Nathan has an amazing opportunity here
because he's got four months
to get sober, so that when he goes
to treatment, he can really unpack his shit
and create this amazing foundation for himself.
You don't have to wait
until treatment to focus on your sobriety.
It's been impressed upon you that you are an alcoholic.
I gather that you agree with this sentiment and
that elevator's going down.
And there's no guarantee that if you decide to drink
or use tonight, that you're gonna wake up the next day,
you could get into a car wreck, you could kill somebody,
you could harm yourself, like all bets are off.
Every time you decide to take
that substance into your body, there is a good chance
that something terrible is gonna happen into your life.
And that's something that you can't control.
And as an alcoholic, that's part
of the allure, we can romanticize that.
But the harsh truth is that
you don't have the luxury of doing that anymore.
And I think this intervention probably has put a damper
on how fun that high is gonna be anyway,
because every time you drink
or use now in the back of your mind, you're like,
"I'm going to treatment, everybody knows I'm an alcoholic."
And the kind of beating up that you do.
Like I'm a piece of shit and all of that,
like why can't I stop this?
So congrats on agreeing to go to treatment, that's huge.
But I really, and you know this,
like I'm just reminding you of what you already know
that you can lean into your addiction and just say, fuck it
and party down until you have to go,
or you have this amazing opportunity
to start taking care of yourself right now.
So why would you wait until treatment
when you need to get sober right now?
You do seem to have some level
of willingness that you're trying to like,
on some level, you're looking for an excuse, right?
Like you need to get sober, you know
what to do in order to get sober, you go to an AA meeting.
It's sounds like he negotiated himself four months.
Yeah, he's trying to,
I think what he wants is for me to say,
"It's cool, rock it out for the next four months,
'cause you're going to treatment."
Or he wants to feel better
about that decision that he's already made for himself.
And that's not the right decision.
Pick up the phone, find an AA meeting near you, show up,
raise your hand, listen, find somebody you can talk to,
go out for coffee with them, be honest with them.
Find a sponsor, start getting into the steps now,
you don't have to think about this in the context
of four months, break it down into what you're doing today.
Is your head gonna hit the pillow tonight sober or isn't it?
What can you control in your exact present moment
that is gonna set you up for being the most sober person
you can be when you go to the treatment center.
I don't know what else to tell you.
I mean, the answer's pretty simple.
I think that he already knows the answer to this.
So it's a matter of cultivating
the willingness to take that action.
When the alcohol like is nodding on the back
of your brain saying, "It's okay, you can go out."
One thing he kept.
"You've got four months."
One thing he kept bringing up
is how it's enmeshed with anxiety and depression.
Does that impact you in any way?
Do you have anything to speak to about that?
Well, it's impossible to,
first of all, I'm not a psychologist or a psychiatrist,
but like it's a very difficult
to adequately diagnose somebody's mental wellbeing
if they're drinking and using all the time.
The first thing you have to do is dry them out, right?
And then see what you're dealing with.
But oftentimes the depression or the anxiety
creates a vicious cycle, where it's like the only way out
is to use or to escape those painful emotions is to use
and you get some relief from that.
But obviously, ultimately,
that is contributing to those conditions.
And so you get yourself caught
in this like hamster wheel situation with that.
So yeah, maybe if you get rid of it,
you stop using, some of those emotions are gonna come
to the surface and they might be more severe
in the short run, which is all the more reason why
you need to seek out help for this.
Like, don't do this alone.
You don't have to do this alone.
There are communities of people ready, willing,
and able to help you,
who can help instill in you these tools
and help you learn how to practice these tools
that will alleviate some of that discomfort over time
and provide you with the ability
to kind of manage your emotional state
free of drugs and alcohol.
That is gonna be super important in not only getting sober,
but ultimately staying sober.
Perfect, love it. Good luck Nathan.
So Nathan, get over yourself this four months.
No, no, you know what do, he knows what he is doing.
You've been intervened on, Nathan.
Consider this an additional digital intervention.
You've been intervened on twice now, bro.
You asked for this.
All right, I like this last one.
Hi Rich, hi Adam.
My name is Kate, I live in Reno, Nevada.
I am a divorced mom of three boys in my early 30s
and I have a new partner that I am super happy with.
I have struggled with drinking for a lot of years.
I do loss of like quote-unquote, sober stints,
90 days, 100 days, 30 days, but I always seem
to come back to this area of trying to moderate.
In the last year, I have really put my foot down,
trying very hard not to drink.
Anyways, I have this awesome new partner.
We've been together for about six months now
and there are a lot of really great things.
He's also divorced.
So we came into this looking for very similar things,
knowing what we didn't do great
in past relationships, we have very open communication.
We do all the same things,
we run and ski and hot spring, a lot of great things.
However, he likes to drink a lot, especially on weekends.
We'll be nice and healthy all week and then on the weekends,
it's definitely kind of a binge drinking thing
and it's become an issue between us, I can't do that.
I don't have the ability to moderate, I know that.
I either don't drink or I black out, basically.
So it's kind of become this thing between us.
And I'm wondering if you have any words of wisdom or advice.
If a someone who is really trying to get sober
and be sober forever can be with someone
who doesn't want to do that.
We have talked about this
and he doesn't drink for emotional reasons.
He just drinks because he likes
to drink or it's not covering up anything.
And he doesn't consider his drinking a problem.
So he does of not want to stop.
And it's hard for me to be with someone
who wants to do that, even though
there are always other amazing traits
about our relationship, any tidbits would help.
Thank you guys, love you both, talk to you later, bye.
Oh, Kate, I'm so sympathetic to this predicament.
It's a tough one, right?
Yeah, definitely I mean you have a,
it's tough I think to find,
especially when you're a divorced parent,
it's tough to find someone that is gonna jive
with all that and to be connected to them
and then find someone that you really like on top of that.
And it's all seems to be working on the surface
and then find this one thing kind of one thing,
but the six month mark though is when these one things
start to really shine, don't they?
Like that six month mark.
You kinda present yourself in a certain way
for only so long until the true self is revealed.
So a couple things here.
I mean, first of all, the notion, this idea
of being able to drink like a gentleman or a gentlewoman
in moderation is of course the great obsession
of every alcoholic, many take that to their grave.
Like, oh, if I just do it like this,
then I'll be able to figure it out.
And what's cool is that like Kate has kind
of come to this place, where she realizes moderation is out.
Either you don't drink or she blacks out.
So it's not for me to diagnose whether
she's an alcoholic or not that's for her to diagnose.
But I think if she's honest
with herself, that she is in a place where she realizes
that her relationship with alcohol is problematic, right?
So she is endeavoring
to be sober and find a way forward with that.
And if it wasn't so, this wouldn't bother her.
Correct, right?
If you're not an alcoholic, then you're not, it's.
It doesn't bother you if your boyfriend's drinking.
Yeah, exactly.
I do think it wasn't clear,
whether Kate is getting any kind of outside help for this.
So I would encourage Kate
that you check out AA, get a program going.
And then you have a community
of people with whom you can communicate about this problem.
At the same time, I think
with respect to the challenges you're having
with your partner, Al-Anon is where you should be.
I think you'll find a lot of help
in those rooms in terms of helping you guide yourself
through these relationship issues,
because it's basically people talking
about how they deal with the alcoholics in their lives.
And I'm not saying that your boyfriend
is an alcoholic or not, but I do think,
well, first of all, he's an unreliable narrator.
For him to say, like, "I don't drink for emotional reasons,"
and it's just like, I like to do or whatever.
Like you can't trust that, that's something
that every alcoholic would say anyway.
But either way alcoholic or not,
what I see, or what I hear in what you shared
is someone who is resistant to supporting you
in this way, like his refusal to see, or to acknowledge
that his habits around alcohol are negatively impacting you
and his reluctance to modify his behavior in any way
leads me to question just how supportive
he is in this relationship.
Like, you're like, he's awesome,
and we like doing all of these things together
and it must feel good coming out of a divorce too,
as Adam said, find somebody
who shares like the kind of activities that you like to do.
And it sounds like you guys are on the same page
on a lot of stuff, so it's tough but
I think the thing for you
to do is to do a real honest inventory
on what kind of relationship you really wanna have.
Like, is this person helping you
become the person that you aspire to be?
And it kind of doesn't seem that way.
Not based on this message.
No and why would you wanna be with somebody who
isn't willing to be supportive of you in this regard?
And why is it so hard for you to have
a healthy boundary around this issue?
Like, is this a pattern?
Have you been in relationships
with guys like this in the past?
Men who don't adequately support or respect you.
And I think the hard fact, hard truth
is if you really wanna be emotionally sober
and pursue this sober life, having a partner
who likes to go balls out
on the weekend really is not a great dynamic.
And generally in my experience, doesn't end up boding well.
So either you're gonna end up starting
to drink again, or this is gonna come to a head
and you guys are gonna have a big fight about this.
So that's my big speech.
I mean, I think getting sober
and staying sober isn't just about drinking,
it's about like I said, a minute ago, emotional sobriety.
And emotional sobriety means
developing these tools and practicing these tools
to help you develop self respect,
to create healthy boundaries.
And ultimately, it means surrounding yourself
with like-minded people and having the self-esteem
to remove yourself from situations and people who are not
in alignment with the kind of emotional stability
and support that you frankly deserve in your life.
So again, it's hard, it's complicated.
It doesn't mean that he's a bad person,
but you do deserve somebody who really sees you,
who understands you, who supports you.
And is living a lifestyle that's congruent
with the kind of lifestyle you aspire to have for yourself.
So the question really is this guy serving that
or is his presence in your life working at odds with that?
And then the final note I would say,
is it's not about getting him to change.
You need to kind of leave that aside and focus on yourself
and what do you want and what do you wanna change?
It's about your own change
and it's about valuing that and protecting that.
I think well said, my friend.
Yeah, I don't have much to add Kate,
but I do think, I understand why you're,
the good aspects of this relationship too.
So I just wanna say that I see that
and understand why this is a dilemma for you.
Because of the good stuff, this thing is a dilemma.
If the good stuff wasn't there,
wouldn't be a dilemma at all.
So but at the same time, I agree with Rich,
that you need to prioritize yourself
and your wellbeing within the relationship.
And I think that's hard to do, especially like,
she sounds like she spends her time in Tahoe and Reno.
And it's like, I know that I know that crowd.
And it's like the women and wanna be chill.
They don't wanna be like controlling women
and like hanging out with this,
in this people who are skiing
and snowboarding, they wanna be the chill one.
They wanna party and I get it, and there's
an urge, there's a call to the party around the mountain.
I've seen it, I've been there, so I get it.
And I understand that, but I think Rich has some really good
and powerful advice for you.
And the other thing I'd say is being Tahoe, being Tahoe,
there's a lot of guys, the ratio
is in your favor, you know the ratios in your favor.
You don't need me to tell you that,
you know very well the ratio is in your favor.
So no fear.
Right, well, best of luck
to you, Kate, and give us an update, cool.
I think we did it.
Should we have Uncle Jack
teach us to meditate on the way out?
April, this is how my wife understands me.
She was at a bookstore
and she just picked up this selected poems.
Oh, wow.
Not even on the week of his 100th birthday.
Adam would like this.
That what she thought.
I like that.
Isn't that nice?
You married the right one.
Yes.
How to meditate.
Lights out, fall,
hands are collapsed into instantaneous ecstasy,
like a shot of heroin or morphine.
(both laughing)
Should we stop this?
I wish that my experience of meditation was that palpable.
The gland inside of my brain
discharging the good, glad fluid, holy fluid,
as I hap down and hold all my body parts down
to a dead stop trance, healing all my sicknesses,
erasing all, not even the shred of,
I hope you or a loony balloon left in it,
but the mind blank, serene, thoughtless.
When a thought comes a spring in from afar
with its held fourth figure of image,
you spoof it out, you spuff it out, you fake it.
And it fades and thought never comes.
And with joy, you realize for the first time
thinking is just like not thinking.
So I don't have to think anymore.
Beautiful, spuff it out.
Yeah, I'm sorry for the heroin
and morphine reference, that seems like a little bit off.
Like basically he's saying like, this is the same thing.
So here's your healthy alternative.
That's it.
And meditation is right out of the steps, baby.
There you go, baby.
So way to lay the plane, my brother.
It's good to be here, you seem in a better mood.
Was this good for you?
It was good therapeutic.
Was it good for you?
Yeah it got my mind off of my dading dilemmas.
You're my dad idol.
Please.
If you saw what goes on in our house,
you might think twice about that.
(both laughing)
Noted.
Set you sites higher, my friend.
Noted, noted.
No, it's parenting is,
for me has been this accumulation of experiences where
there are these notches in my belt
and each little experience that you have,
you think you become this better parent
and you have a stronger grip
on like what to do and what not to do and what to say.
And those kind of patterns that you've learned
from your parents that you know are not right,
are less and less frequent.
'Cause if I'm not taking care
of myself, I'll react in a way that is the way
that one of my parents did that I didn't like
and I have to be very conscious.
But every time I think like I got a handle
on this life, throws some crazy curve ball situation
at me that I've never experienced before.
And this sort of degree of difficulty
continues to like ratchet up unrelenting.
And that's the gift, the joy, the challenge of all of it.
But it's painful when you have these people
in your life that are living
in your house and you care for them so much,
when things don't, like when things don't work out,
you're just like, "Ugh, it's so painful."
To feel their pain, anyway.
It all goes together.
That's landing the plane right there.
So we'll be back in a couple weeks
until then, you know where to find this guy
@Adamskolnick on the socials.
I'm @Richroll, easy to find,
subscribe to the YouTube channel if you haven't already.
It's easier to spell Roll.
In all the platforms, Skolnick,
how do people misspell your last name?
Can I pitch you something
for next time before you get into the credits?
Yeah.
The Rollies.
It's the Oscars.
It's Oscar season, we gotta watch the movies.
I've seen most of them.
All right, the Rollies.
Have you seen "Drive My Car"
No, I have to see that.
I haven't seen that or "CODA."
It's three hours long
and it's about someone driving around in a car,
it scares me.
I know.
Good that will be fun, let's do that.
The Rollies.
All right, cool.
Awesome, if you would like your message considered
for us to discuss on the show,
leave us voicemail at (424) 235-4626.
You can find the show notes and links to everything
that we discussed on the episodepage@richroll.com.
Again, please subscribe to the show, if you haven't already
on whatever platform you're enjoying this content.
And I wanna thank the team for all the hard work
that they put in to creating this show week in week out.
Jason Blake, Dan Daniel, AJ, Davey, Georgia, DK,
Tyler Trapper, Hari for some music, the theme music.
Thanks for the love you guys,
see you back here in a couple days,
with another amazing announcement, until then peace.
Plans.
(both whispering)
(upbeat music)